Good googly Mowgli.
Hello everybody.
Welcome back.
This episode of the Joe Rogan experience
podcast is brought to you by tank.
Ting is one of my favorite sponsors on
the podcast because I have heard nothing
but positive responses from people that
have used ting and have saved money.
It's a no bullshit and mobile service
and what they mean by no bullshit is
they have no contracts,
no early termination fees,
no ridiculous bundling or ride along
services,
the way they set up their rates.
You use what you use and you pay for
what you use.
No overage charges,
no penalties,
no add on charges,
no mysterious line items on your bill.
They decided to put together a mobile
service the way mobile really should
have been done from the beginning with
no nonsense and good service.
They use this sprint backbone,
so you have a major provider that's
providing your bandwidth,
providing your,
your cell phone service,
and you can get the top end android
devices.
When you buy a device from Ting,
if you go to Tim's website,
if you go to [inaudible] dot [inaudible]
dot com,
you can actually save $25 off one of
these android devices,
but if you see the range of devices that
they have,
they have all the cool new gadgets like
the Samsung galaxy s three,
the Samsung Galaxy s four actually is
the new one,
the Samsung Galaxy note three,
which is what I have.
The htc one.
I mean they have all the really cool,
interesting new android phones,
so you get the high end phones,
you get sprint service.
It's exactly the same as sprint.
It's not some weird mom and pop company
that's giving you some rinky dink cell
phone service and you can do it and save
money and do it in a way where you don't
feel gross at the end of the month like
that.
Got Me.
These fucking creeps to kindle team will
also give you credit for $25 of your
early termination fee up to $75 per
device.
Twenty five percent rather.
I'll say that again.
Tim will give you.
It's.
They call it their early termination fee
relief program,
which is kind of sweet.
They will give you credit for 25 percent
of your early termination fee up to $75
per device.
So if you're getting fucked by your
other company when you leave and go to
tank,
they'll try to give you a little bit of
relief.
It's a really cool way to get your
mobile service.
It's really cool way that they've
decided to provide mobile service.
Just no nonsense.
And it's ethical.
It's clean,
it's a better way to do it.
Um,
we have friends that use it and it's
been nothing but positive.
We've had nothing but excellent
responses.
So go to [inaudible] dot ting.com.
Saved money and better manage your
mobile service using ting.
So that's Rogan.ting.com.
And save some money.
Well you were also brought to you by
[inaudible] dot com.
That's o n n I t and very excited that
we have Dr Rhonda Patrick on the podcast
today because she can explain some of
the shit that's on it.
That confuses me.
All the baffling stuff about what,
what antioxidants are necessary.
What about,
what about digestive enzymes,
when did they come into play?
All these things are very,
very crucial for health and very
confusing,
so we're going to get to that today,
but on it.com
carries,
we essentially try to carry everything
that we find beneficial and everything
that I use.
Everything that arbor uses,
everything that our friends use,
athletes,
mixed martial arts fighters,
Jujitsu people,
things that things that would benefit
your physical conditioning,
things that would benefit your cognitive
function,
things that benefit your immune system,
your endurance,
what we sell,
whether it's our strength and
conditioning equipment like kettlebells,
battle ropes,
steel,
maces,
those things along those lines,
or whether it's the nutritional
supplements like hemp force protein
powder or new mood or Alpha brain.
We just try to sell you the very best,
most high quality supplements that are
available in the world.
Whatever we can find.
If we find stuff that's beneficial,
we try to sell it to you and because
some of the stuff that we sell at onnit
is controversial.
We're in the process of running many
tests.
We just got back the results where we
actually just started publishing the
results of the double blind placebo
tests that we did on Alpha brain.
If you go to the audit website,
you can see the results of that test.
It was a pilot program of 20 people out
of those 20 people,
a few dropped out.
So we were left with I think 16 or 17
people.
But we got positive results from two
categories,
from memory and from execution.
The execution of a,
I think it's actually verbal execution
was the,
um,
you can learn on a.com.
The idea behind it is what you're doing
when you're taking something like a
nootropic is you're giving your brain
the building blocks to produce human
transmitters.
The nutritional aspects of,
of,
of thought.
And when you take,
you know,
if you're,
if you're just getting that stuff
through food man,
you'd have to take a lot of weird food
and you could take,
you have to take a lot of it in like
really high doses while mosses and
grasses and weird shit that you're not
going to want to eat.
All of it is very controversial,
so we're in the process of continuing
even more studies.
If you go to the website,
you can see the Alpha brain clinical
trial results.
We have them all posted and we're in the
process of a much larger test right now.
We're also in the process of tests on
several of the other supplements because
they're controversial even though we 100
percent back them and support them,
we offer a 30 pill,
90 day 100 percent money back guarantee
on anything that you buy from on it and
either supplements.
If you try them,
you don't like them.
You feel like Alpha brain didn't make
your brain work any better.
You get 100 percent of your money back.
You don't even have to send in the
pills.
We don't want anybody feeling ripped
off.
We just want to sell you the best shit
that's available currently.
So go to [inaudible] dot com o n n I t
use the Codeword Rogan and save 10
percent off of any and all supplements.
All right,
that's it.
Boom,
boom.
Dr Rhonda Patrick's here.
Cue The music.
I'm just dying to ask you,
so what's in Alpha brain,
the Joe Rogan experience?
Joe Rogan podcast all day?
That's a good question.
What's an APA?
Brandon?
We could read it all off,
but it would sound like another
commercial on top of a commercial.
It's essentially you said a transmitter
or somebody can serotonin.
I'm looking.
Doo Doo,
Doo Doo Doo.
I should give it to you so you could
read it.
Yeah.
Because,
uh,
if trip to fans in there,
that's actually a really.
Hold on a second,
but this is just one.
This has alpha brand that has a lot of
different shit in it.
It is the stuff that we take.
Um.
Oh Wow.
Yeah.
Okay.
That's A.
Here's the actual ingredients.
Read that right there.
Dr Rhonda Patrick reached out to me,
um,
because she had some things to say about
some of the things that other podcast
guests said about nutrition,
about health,
and tell the folks what your credentials
are,
what you do,
who you are,
why you are uniquely qualified to
explain nutrition and health to his
phone.
Absolutely.
So my name is Rhonda Patrick,
I have a phd in biomedical science.
I did my undergraduate work in
biochemistry,
chemistry,
um,
and now I'm doing a postdoctoral
fellowship,
um,
nutrition and metabolism.
So I,
uh,
started out with synthesizing peptides
and doing organic chemistry and I got
really bored with that and I was a
undergraduate student research and
research and intern.
So then I decided to try biology out and
I went to the Sulk Institute for
Biological Sciences in La Jolla and I
did some research on aging using worms
as a model because they haven't really
short lifespan.
And so it was really cool to do a lot of
genetic manipulation and see how that
changed our lifespan.
And from there I was like,
oh my God,
I freaking love this.
I want to get my phd in biology.
And I decided to go to Memphis,
Tennessee because a,
I wanted to do research on cancer.
And a St Jude Children's Research
Hospital is located in Memphis,
Tennessee.
So I ended up going to University of
Tennessee to get my phd,
but I did all my research at St Jude.
Absolutely fantastic place.
And then,
uh,
so I was doing a lot of research using
mice and um,
some human cells and then I decided I
wanted a moment,
people just glossing over that I did
research with mice and human cells and I
mean I could go on and on about my
actual research mice people.
No,
no,
I didn't make,
I've been most people.
But um,
I,
I did a lot of work on Mitochondria and
mitochondrial metabolism and how that
relates to cancer and how cells die and
how they don't die and what,
you know,
what's going wrong with cancer.
And I got a really awesome publication
out of it and uh,
nature.
And um,
then I decided that I was really wanting
to move on to something,
you know,
during your phd you like dig,
dig,
dig deep deep mechanism,
you know.
And finally you got to get,
you just keep digging deeper.
And I felt like I was lost from like
what everything meant and what was the
significance of it,
you know?
And so,
and you kind of have to do that in Grad
school because you're learning the
tools,
you know,
how to use tools to answer questions,
what kind of questions and how you
answered them.
And so,
uh,
I did really a lot of that and,
um,
then I decided I wanted to kind of take
a step back and look at the big picture
and,
uh,
do some clinical research and apply the
tools that I learned in graduate school
and try to learn some things using,
you know,
looking at,
people.
Um,
so now I'm at the Children's Hospital
Oakland Research Institute.
We're working with Bruce Ames,
a WHO's pretty famous for his aims test
carcinogenicity test where he basically
made this test.
I could help you figure out whether or
not a chemical was a Mutagen,
meaning it caused cancer.
Um,
and so I'm working with him and I'm
actually looking at,
um,
what causes the amount of looking at a
lot of things.
But I'm actually a fundamentally looking
at people that are obese and how obesity
accelerates the aging process of people
that are obese,
die,
have all sorts of age related diseases
sooner.
Cardiovascular disease,
type two diabetes,
cancer by the age of 40.
They like there's a 14 year,
a reduction in their lifespan,
which is I think even greater than
smoking cigarettes.
So I'm trying to understand fundamental
fundamental mechanisms like why these
people are accelerating their aging
process.
And so I'm actually looking at something
specifically.
I'm looking at their DNA.
So,
um,
I'm taking blood cells so we draw blood
from people that have a bmi of 30 or
above or 25 and below which are
considered normal or lean,
which is body mass index.
And you know,
it's just problems with like using body
mass index as a marker for,
you know,
obesity,
because,
you know,
some people,
some people are,
you know,
lean and anyways,
it's,
it's kind of marquee,
but I'm not going to go into that.
So I'm actually looking at a.
So I take their,
their blood cells and I,
I look at their DNA.
Um,
and how much damages in their DNA,
and I kinda want to get into that a
little later.
I'm kind of explain what that is,
but that's Kinda what I'm doing.
Um,
I'm also doing some research on vitamin
D and I have a paper that's actually
coming out in six days.
It's going to hit the press.
Um,
I found that vitamin D actually regulate
Serotonin,
so it's really cool.
That makes sense for people in Seattle.
Don't get any vitamin D,
they don't get any sun.
They're all bummed out.
It ain't no thing.
Every winter people in northern
latitudes,
a lot of,
a lot of people are,
uh,
having adequate levels of vitamin D.
So it's,
it's a really important finding to.
So that can actually affect your mood.
Supplementing with vitamin D when you
live in a place where it doesn't get
sun.
No,
I'm not going to talk about the details
of this paper because there's like an
embargo and all that,
but I will talk about absolutely
serotonin affects mood behavior,
you know,
so that's why I was asking if Tryptofan
was in your Alpha brain because trip to
fan is a rare amino acid that occurs in
protein and most people think that,
oh,
I eat Turkey,
I'm getting my trip to fan.
But the thing is is that trip to fan,
in order to get converted into Serotonin
has to get transported into your brain
through this transporter.
It converts to five htp,
correct.
It does convert to convert to that we
have five htp and then it converts into
Serotonin.
Yeah.
That's one of the principle of
ingredients and knew mood knew mood is a
five htp and defend the idea being that
there's a sort of a slow release effect.
The ultra defend converts to five htp
and then five htp convert to Serotonin.
Five htp can actually cross the blood
brain barrier so that can already get
converted into Serotonin in your brain
and and Tryptophan.
So tryptophan actually competes with
other branch chain amino acids like
Leucine,
leucine,
to get transported into the brain and it
loses.
So losing these branched chain amino
acids they're at and protein.
So what ends up happening if you're not
taking something like five htp or
something else,
is that um,
most of the time you're not getting
enough tryptophan transport into your
brain.
Now certain things can help alleviate
that competition like exercise.
So exercise.
You take up a bunch of branch chain
amino acids to make muscle.
So exercise actually boost Serotonin in
your brain by allowing Tryptofan to get
transporting to brain.
Alleviating some of that competition
from other branch chain amino acids.
Yeah,
and actually it's really interesting.
They've done,
you can actually deplete someone's brain
tryptofan by giving them a big bolus
shake of branch chain amino acids
because then it really out competes all
the trip to fan that you've from your
diet and within like four or five hours,
you can deplete like 90 percent of
someone's brain serotonin.
And then they do all these like
behavioral tests to see what,
you know,
what the,
what the results are,
what,
how,
how not having Serotonin in your brain
impacts behavior and cognitive function.
And they found that it really,
there's a lot of things that are sort of
messed up if you're not making
Serotonin,
you become impulsive,
impulsive behavior.
Your longterm thinking kind of,
you know,
shuts down.
Um,
some of your method.
He actually,
there's a study,
there was a study where they compared
methamphetamine users,
cocaine users,
and then they depleted just normal
people.
They depleted their trip fan by that
method I just told you about and
depleting the trip to fan.
So basically depleting the Serotonin in
your brain.
You were your do your scoring just as
bad as a meth user.
And Actually Meth Amphetamine Does
Deplete Your Sarah Tone.
Isn't that frightening?
Wow.
So that's wild wild.
You know,
Sarah,
the fact that serotonin's affecting our
behavior and that it's basically,
you know,
Tryptophan and vitamin D are important
for that.
People don't realize,
you know,
nutrition effects,
effects the way your brain works.
It does.
And it's so confusing.
And when you're a regular person that's
trying to go online or read books about
health and nutrition and what you need,
what you don't need,
there's so much contradictory
information.
There's so many people that tell you you
don't need anything.
Just a balanced diet.
Well,
what's a balanced diet?
Well then that gets squirrely.
You know,
the balanced diet includes grains.
Whoa.
No,
don't eat gluten.
Gluten's bad,
you know,
stay away from eggs,
eggs contain,
you know,
it just gets so weird.
There's so much information.
It's so hard to separate the wheat from
the chaff.
That's the expression,
right?
Wheat from the chaff.
Totally agree.
So much noise out there.
And it's very confusing.
Um,
you know,
and it's,
yeah,
you get getting your nutrition from your
diet.
Well that would be ideal.
But the reality is we have,
you know,
the National Institute of Medicine that
we're conducting these surveys every
five years.
They call them the nutrition and
examination health surveys.
And hanes is very notorious.
Um,
you know,
in the nutrition field there,
we consider n hanes surveys to be pretty
accurate in determining what people are
getting from their diet.
And you know,
these surveys are telling us no,
people are not getting what they need
from their diet.
The majority of Americans are not
getting what they need in terms of,
you know,
micronutrients.
Yeah,
it's really hard to do so.
And to do so on a daily basis requires
you to really eat clean and healthy.
Mean you can get what you need from your
diet.
But boy,
you have to really mind what you're
eating.
You have to really work at it.
And it's,
yeah,
it's a lot of effort.
Um,
you know,
it's,
and there's also the difference between
the idea of you just surviving and not
getting a disease and you being at
optimal health.
Absolutely,
absolutely.
That's something that our lab works on,
you know,
but where we've got this sort of theory
that it,
it's hard to do aging studies in people
and particularly looking at different,
you know,
vitamins and minerals and what effects
they have longterm.
Um,
but that's,
that's one of the theories in our lab
that we've shown some evidence of it,
um,
is that,
you know,
the,
a lot of vitamins and minerals,
there are cofactors for many different
biochemical pathways in your body.
Like if you were just gonna go buy a
biochemical pathways,
you'll see this massive image come up
and it's just like holy crap,
like,
and vitamins and minerals are cofactors
for enzymes,
meaning they need to be there for the
enzyme to work optimally in enzymes and
proteins in your body are doing
everything.
I mean,
that's what's right and what's doing
everything everybody's doing.
Um,
and so if you don't have,
you know,
there's certain proteins that are
important to survive right now,
like your sodium potassium atpase know,
you want to make sure your heart's
getting the right signals you want.
I mean,
if that shuts down,
then you're dead,
you know.
So I mean,
some of these,
some of these functions are more
important.
So that's the biochemical pathways.
I'm talking about these.
And that's just a snapshot,
that's just a snapshot.
So,
I mean,
all these different pathways,
they require vitamins and minerals,
essential fatty acids.
I mean,
these things,
it's complicated.
And so cheeseburgers don't,
don't give that everything it needs.
No,
they don't.
They don't.
And what,
you know,
what is it,
what is it that someone should
absolutely supplement with on a daily
basis?
You know,
I would say definitely most people are
not getting enough vitamin D and that
is,
it's a steroid hormone.
It's a hormone that controls the
expression of over a thousand different
genes in our body,
which is literally like 24th of our
human genome,
many of them in our brain.
Um,
so what that means is without vitamin D,
so vitamin D is so important that we can
make it from the sun.
Problem is,
we're not,
we're not doing that anymore.
Most of us aren't out in the sun a lot,
you know,
I know I'm not,
I'm always at my computer inside.
Um,
and when I'm out I'm,
you know,
we're worried about skin aging if you're
a female or skin cancer,
you know,
and so I'm bring sunscreen of course.
Um,
and as a majority of the people from the
surveys,
you know,
if you look at people that supplement
and don't supplement in the United
States,
about 70 percent don't get adequate
levels of vitamin D and actually the way
we determine what's adequate is based on
vitamin D's classical function of bone
homeostasis,
you know,
so we know vitamin D is important to
make sure that our bones don't,
don't start breaking down,
but in fact there's a thousand other
things it's doing and we don't know how
much vitamin D we need to do those other
things,
but to at least maintain that,
that's considered adequate.
And that's like 30 nanograms per
milliliter of the precursor vitamin D
called 25 Hydroxyvitamin d,
which is what most people,
when you get your levels measured,
that's what they measure.
So what should you take on a daily
basis?
I would say,
you know,
definitely you should probably be taking
a vitamin D supplement.
And what dose do you think?
So here's the thing,
you know,
a lot of different things regulate
vitamin D,
absorption and bioavailability.
Body fat,
for one,
it is a fat soluble vitamin.
So the more body fat you have,
the more it's stored in that fat and the
less of it can be released in the
bloodstream to be circulated and brought
to different organs in your body and
then get into the cells to do its thing.
Um,
so people that are obese actually
require much higher levels of vitamin D
because it will be,
you know,
it's been shown that vitamin D
bioavailability is reduced by up to 50
percent and like severely obese people.
So that's one thing to consider is how
much per body fat,
body,
fat.
Um,
I think generally a good marker is like
a thousand I use per 25 pounds,
but like I said,
25 pounds.
You can be 25 pounds of muscle.
And so,
you know,
I think the best way to really gauge how
much vitamin D you need is to just get a
test.
Just go,
you know,
if you,
if you have health insurance,
health insurance pays for it.
Um,
there's other places that you can get
vitamin D levels tested cheaply,
very cheaply and it's just so worth it.
Like,
I get mine tested routinely because I
just want to make sure that my,
you know,
dosing is pretty good.
Like I personally take 4,000
Ius a day.
Is that a lot?
Um,
I think that's pretty,
pretty standard for an adult.
Uh,
that's,
you know,
normal weight and in pretty good shape.
Uh,
yeah,
I think that's pretty standard,
but I can't say that everyone should go
out and take 4,000.
I use a day.
It can say that you should definitely
make sure that you have levels in your
blood that's higher than 30 nanograms
per milliliter,
which is above the adequate status.
And actually,
if we look at studies where they've
looked at,
for example,
all car cause mortality,
lowering,
all calls,
mortality,
they've shown that,
um,
you know,
huge like large cohort studies.
They've done,
they've looked at the levels of vitamin
D and then looked at mortality,
dying of different,
you know,
diseases,
uh,
people with levels of vitamin D between
40 and 60 nanograms per milliliter and
their blood had the least amount of all
cores caused mortality.
So basically they were living the
longest.
Um,
so,
you know,
maybe you want to have between 40 and 60
nanograms per milliliter or based on
that study,
uh,
you know,
it's,
it's important to get the levels tested.
That's,
that's Kinda what I like to,
uh,
advocate because it's so cheap and easy
use
and why not very few people ever get the
body tested for their vitamin levels.
It's,
it's,
it is kind of unusual that we think
about health and nutrition,
but how few people actually get their
blood tested.
It's the future really.
I mean we're going to start to do that.
It preventative medicine,
being able to know if we have adequate
amounts of vitamin minerals,
it's gonna get easier and easier the
next couple of decades.
I think you reached out to me because of
people on the podcast saying things that
you didn't think were accurate and you
got upset and sent me some videos and
some,
some different things.
So the sort of describe what
disinformation these people were
releasing more erroneous information,
right?
Like,
give us some specifics.
So what thing will,
let's just talk about what bugged you.
One of the erroneous facts were that
most people,
most Americans,
get all the micronutrients they need
from their diet.
That was Brian Dunning.
That was Brian.
Denny is not proportionately based on,
you know,
the National Institute of Medicine doing
these surveys.
We know that's not correct.
And in fact they've even done surveys
where they've,
you know,
looked at people that supplement versus
people
that don't supplement and people that
supplement have much more adequate
levels of these certain vitamins and
minerals.
So,
you know,
that's,
that's already the first thing that's
not true.
Um,
and the,
you know,
the,
this recent editorial that came out in
the annals of internal medicine was
really upsetting because they were
basically saying that multivitamins do
nothing and not only do they nothing,
do nothing,
they're bad for you.
And you mentioned that,
you actually mentioned that on that
podcast that you had with dunning.
Yeah.
That's,
that research that they.
First of all,
I think it's one of most irresponsible
studies or the most irresponsible press
releases I've ever read because if you
actually read what the studies were in
comparison to what they're saying,
they're saying vitamins don't work,
case closed,
but the studies that they did were on
Alzheimer's patients not showing a any
sort of improvement.
People over 65 that had heart attacks
not showing any improvement.
I mean just those two things were two
out of the three tasks that they did at.
They're saying that vitamins don't work
when you're talking about a generic
multivitamin to synthetic multivitamins,
one of those centrum ones,
those ones that they find in the bottom
of Porta potties.
By the way,
when they clean out,
they find them.
They find those little blue pills still
like intact,
like they pass through people's back.
Allegedly that might not be true.
I've never learned.
What do I know if I even looked online
to research.
Now I'm just parroting it like little
minor bird,
but the studies themselves were were
really shocking.
I mean,
I'll read you the the three things.
A male physicians over 65 showed no
improvement in cognitive decline using a
generic multivitamins supplementation
like they're dying.
Oh God.
Can I please just tell me that?
So that study was so infuriating because
they were giving these,
these guys six.
Okay.
This was supposed to be a high dose
multivitamin and they were giving him
six pills a day.
Six pills a day.
Okay.
I take a high dose multivitamin.
It's one pill a day.
Okay.
And their,
their total vitamin D levels were,
were like 100.
I use like 100 I use a vitamin D won't
do anything and that was considered a
high dose.
And their compliance meaning.
Okay,
you're asking someone to take six pills
a day for like 10 years.
And then you,
you call them up every three months.
And did you take your six pills?
Well,
I took it yesterday.
So,
you know.
Yeah,
I took it for the last three months.
They didn't measure any,
there was no quantitative like
biochemical analysis,
meaning they didn't measure any,
uh,
any vitamins like choose one vitamin
that's in that your,
your multivitamin concoction and see if
what you're giving them actually raises
the level of that,
you know,
to show that they're a compliance,
be that you're giving them a dose that's
actually doing something.
So you're leaving it up to the person to
take it as well.
And especially when you're doing the
study,
they did.
Yeah,
that's,
that seems pretty faulty.
And also you say that you take 4,000
units and they had 100.
That's not so good.
The other aspect of the study was that
high dose multivitamins had no effect on
the progression of heart disease and
heart attack survivors.
Again,
they're dying,
right?
These are dying people.
I mean this is not people who.
Preventative medicine is what.
One of the things you talked about
earlier about testing blood.
And I,
I really think that that is the key.
It's not about catching you when you're
falling apart.
It's about making sure you don't fall
apart.
Giving your body the natural building
blocks to repair cells to keep your body
healthy from the jump.
And that's what we should be doing.
We should be doing in intelligently
thinking ahead while you're healthy,
while you're young.
It's so true.
I mean,
I'll give you an example.
So 45 percent of the US population
doesn't have adequate levels of
magnesium and you know,
I think,
I think most people in the fitness
community are concerned with magnesium
because they're always like,
oh my God,
I sweat it out.
I got to replace my magnesium.
You know,
I think that's their major concern or
muscle cramping and things like that.
But magnesium is an essential cofactor
for a DNA repair enzymes.
So let me explain what that is,
because poorly,
what's DNA repair enzymes.
So,
you know,
uh,
everyday just normal metabolism.
So our mitochondria are there,
they're taking food that we eat in,
whether it's carbohydrates or protein or
fat,
and they're generating what's called
electron reducing equivalents through
this whole krebs cycle.
If you ever learned in biochemistry and
those electron reducing equivalents are
really important because they have a
hydrogen which has an electron.
And a proton and these electrons get
passed along inside your Mitochondria,
these various proteins,
and they shoot out protons at the same
time and this is basically the way it
generally generates energy to then take
the oxygen you breathe in and reduce it
to water and couple that to making ATP
anyways so these electrons get passed
around and what happens is they often,
because you're taking oxygen,
you breathe in and making water to
generate the energy you need to make
atp.
You start making super oxide and on and
you start making reactive oxygen species
in your Mitochondria.
Everyday we're doing this,
we're doing it right now.
I mean that's the major source of
reactive oxygen species.
I'm sure you've heard of that.
And your body.
I'm in these reactive oxygen species.
They react.
That's what they do.
They react with your DNA,
the react with liquids.
Your cell membranes erected the proteins
and the damage and what happens when
you're doing,
it's called DNA damage.
When it reacts with Your Dna,
you know,
sometimes you get like an,
a,
you know,
a bulky Adec that's attached on or
sometimes you get like an oxide of
product which then can cause a break.
Your DNA is double stranded and cause a
break.
And what happens is,
you know,
the cells in your,
in different organs like your kidneys
and your liver,
these cells have a limited lifespan.
And so they have to replicate,
you know,
I'd have to synthesize their DNA
replicate in order to replace their
limited lifespan.
So,
um,
when the cell then tries to replicate
its DNA and there's just like funny
stuff there,
it doesn't,
it's like what is this?
And then sometimes it puts another
nucleotide,
what's not supposed to be there and it
causes a mutation and then you have this
mutation.
It's like,
okay,
well you can't go back once you have a
mutation,
it's there.
So,
you know,
if it's a mutation in a coding region of
a gene that does something important,
then you could really screw stuff up.
And so,
um,
in order to prevent that from happening,
we have what's called DNA repair
enzymes.
Okay,
and they basically take this damage
that's there and they repair it and
those DNA repair enzymes require
magnesium without magnesium.
They do not work,
did not work well.
They're very inefficient.
And so if you're not getting enough
magnesium,
your DNA repair isn't going well and
you're probably getting more damaged.
But the thing is that this is,
this is a decade,
it takes decades for this to rear its
head.
You know,
you've got a bunch of you and we've got
DNA damage,
but you can't look in the mirror and be
like,
oh,
I have DNA damage today.
You know,
it's like,
well,
you can look in the mirror and be like,
oh my gums are falling apart.
I probably have scurvy.
So it's like,
you know,
this is something you can't see and what
happens is over a year,
over decades of getting this DNA damage,
because it happens at random places in
your genes.
Eventually you get it into place that
you don't want.
You get it in a gene that's important
for controlling cell cycle or stopping
bad cells from dividing and
proliferating.
These are called tumor suppressor genes
and when you get it in one of those,
you're screwed because now you got some
funky cell that doesn't pass those
checkpoints that usually our genes and
making sure they don't pass the
checkpoint if they're funny,
and then they'll pass it and they start
dividing and proliferating and now
you've got this clonal population of
cancer cells,
but you know,
that takes decades to happen.
So if you're walking around with not,
you know,
not sub adequate levels of magnesium,
you're not going to know anything until
you're in your fifties or sixties and
you know,
you come down with cancer.
Wow.
So that's intense.
So now when you read something like
this,
uh,
you know,
vitamins don't work,
case closed and you find out this is the
research that they did and this is the
conclusion that they came to from the
research.
That's so irresponsible and so
infuriating.
I agree.
It's,
you know,
there's a lot of studies out there that
I've done Meta analyses and shown just
the opposite.
You know,
it's not like this is the only research
that's been done on vitamin and mineral
supplementation.
The thing that's really infuriating is
the big overgeneralizations they did
here,
you know,
for example,
there there is an important case were
taking some vitamins and minerals can be
bad and that is when you have cancer and
you know,
these people had the opportunity to
point that out instead of just saying,
oh,
vitamins or bad meaning like everyone
shouldn't take vitamins.
They have,
you know,
in my opinion they have,
they should,
they should be educating people on,
okay,
well you already have cancer.
This can happen to you.
So you know,
the perfect example is full eight.
Okay.
Full eight isn't essential b vitamin and
it's mostly fortified in a lot of our
breads and even junk food like chips and
I've seen it in chips and crackers and
stuff,
so I'm not that many people in the
United States are deficient in anymore.
I think like 14 percent of the
population.
So it's not a huge,
huge problem.
Like it was.
However I'm full eight is it's essential
to make one of your nucleotides in your
DNA timing,
which means without full eight you're
not making mean and you have to.
You need full eight to basically make
new DNA for these new cells that you're
making in your body every day.
Okay,
so when you don't have full eight,
that can actually cause a single strand
break in your DNA and it can do the
stuff I was telling you about by causing
mutations and leading to cancer
eventually.
However,
if you already have cancer,
everything that's good for you,
cancer,
it's like cancer drugs on crack,
man.
That's like,
oh,
it's good for you.
Yeah,
it gave me some of that.
You know,
it's,
it's like they,
they just take over everything that's
good and because well,
you know,
they want to keep that.
That's their goal,
propagate.
I want to propagate and take over.
So with fall late because cancer cells
are,
they're dividing,
they're trying to replicate themselves.
They love fully.
They love it because that's what they
need to make more DNA to make more of
their cancer cells.
So someone that already has cancer
shouldn't be taking high levels of Foley
and really I think these people that
wrote this editorial had an obligation
to educate them and specifically point
this out.
There's a mechanism why,
let's talk about it instead of making
this huge overgeneralization saying
multivitamins are bad.
What do you think the motivation behind
the study or the conclusion like that
since it seems kind of unscientific,
it's confusing,
like I don't understand why they would
be motivated to say that based on the
findings of the got,
unless putting out that sort of
salacious headline would get people
thinking or get people responding and
cause attention to their work.
Absolutely.
It's,
it's attention grabbing,
negative negative things like that get
press,
they get attention.
I don't know what their motive was.
Honestly.
I F I kind of feel like that's part of
it.
I think another part of it is that a lot
of medical doctors,
they aren't trained in nutrition and
they aren't trained in preventative
medicine.
They aren't trained to understand the
importance of all these vitamins and
minerals and essential fatty acids and
how their cofactors for these proteins
and what they're doing longterm versus
short term.
They're not.
That's,
you know,
when they're trained,
they're.
They're actually trained to understand
how different pharmacological drugs act
on certain receptors.
How that,
you know,
it's,
it's kind of a different training.
So I think in some cases when you start
talking about nutrition and preventative
medicine,
a lot of people,
if you don't know about it and you get
kind of threatened and you feel like,
oh,
it must be wrong,
I don't know about this,
you know,
kind of like one of those responses and
I.
and I think that may also have something
to do with the fish.
A lot of the physicians that are,
we're involved in the,
there's a lot of people that want to be,
there's this,
this is need to be like a no nonsense
person Ho come on and all that.
Who,
that's a bunch of Hooey,
you know,
need any of that so complicated.
Is that a response to not wanting to
delve into the incredibly deep waters of
nutrition and figure out what all these
mechanisms are?
Is it just the sort of a knee jerk
reaction to,
oh,
it's a bunch of bs.
I think there's two.
I think there's two reasons.
I think.
One is absolutely,
it's a visceral response because there
is a load of crap out there and it's
hard.
It is hard to differentiate between
what's the noise in the signal.
And so some people are just like,
oh,
it's all crap,
you know,
but I think there's also people that
just,
it's just too much work.
Like,
you know,
I want to keep eating what I'm eating
and I want to believe it's fine and
that's what I want to believe in.
So I'm going to believe it.
I think that's another really mindset
that needs to be changed.
And I think,
you know,
personally,
I would love to see people eating more,
more Greens.
Um,
you know,
more more of these dark green leafy
vegetables which are rich and many
different micronutrients like vitamin K,
folic acid and magnesium.
Um,
I can talk about that in a minute,
but I think for people that are just,
that aren't going to do that,
you know,
at least give them a vitamin that's
going to give him some of these trace
elements and minerals and vitamin D and
some of these important micronutrients
that they really do need.
Magnesium.
You know,
so at the very least it's just,
it's an easy way to do it,
you know,
it's an easy way to do it.
Yeah.
Some,
it seems to me that in order to really
get a grasp on what is required,
what is necessary for your body,
it takes an incredible amount of study.
I mean there's,
there's so much information that you
have to get,
not just as far as dietary information,
but supplemental information is,
there's just so much.
It's almost feels you feel a little
hopeless.
Like trying to absorb it all and figure
out what,
what you actually need and what you
don't need.
And when you read a study like that,
vitamins don't work.
Case closed.
Good.
Now I can not think.
Let me push that aside and just fucking
have an apple and feel like I'm doing my
job.
You know,
one of the reasons why I made a video to
this,
you know,
responds to this editorial was because,
a,
because I could have done some
scientific paper and gone through peer
review and,
but,
but you know,
I want to get it to the people and it's
like at some level,
you know,
this other scientists,
they don't really care.
I want the people to realize that,
you know,
because these people,
like my dad,
my dad takes a multivitamin and he
listens to the news.
He gets his information from the TV like
that generation does and you know,
it's just,
it's so upsetting.
Like all of a sudden my dad could stop
taking his vitamin and I don't want them
to stop taking his vitamin because it's,
you know,
it's important that he does take his
multivitamin.
Uh,
there,
there are certain,
you know,
think components in that multivitamin
that I know he's not getting from his
diet,
so at least let them get it from his
multivitamin.
So I this,
this study,
there was a Meta analysis that included
like 30 different studies and I really
read through them all and there were a
lot of methodological errors and I point
them out in the video where people were
just,
they weren't measuring levels of any
vitamins and minerals and saying they're
there were measuring some outcome like
cardiovascular disease or cognitive
function without any biomarkers.
Like there was no biomarkers saying,
oh look,
we gave him this,
this changed,
you know,
that's important when you're doing
nutrition research.
Um,
and that's a really important thing.
And if you look at some of the studies
that did do that,
for example,
when they were giving them vitamin D,
they gave him vitamin D to a severely
deficient population,
which is like 12 nanograms per mil.
That's severely deficient.
We're talking like rickets deficient.
And then after their supplementation
they were still deficient.
They were still less than 20 nanograms
per mil,
which is considered deficient.
So it was like,
okay,
well you're trying to look at this
outcome.
And yet the vitamin D supplement,
you know,
the dose that you gave these people was
inadequate.
They didn't,
you didn't raise their levels to
anything,
you know,
that was considered adequate by,
by the National Institute of Medicine.
Now when when people take vitamin D,
which is the exact vitamin D,
they're supposed to take it,
they're supposed to take like d,
Two,
d,
three,
d three.
You can take d two,
but it's just less efficient to get
converted into the active hormone.
T three is optimal.
D three is optimal.
Yeah.
T three is optimal and you know,
like I said,
I personally can't tell people how much
to take.
I can tell them what I take,
which is $4,000
a day and honestly I can tell them that
they should have levels of vitamin D in
their blood greater than 30 nanograms
per mill and we should also tell them,
if you're not familiar with taking
vitamins and minerals,
vitamins need to be taken with food.
Yeah,
I mean you can definitely get nauseous
if you're,
if you're taking your vitamins on an
empty stomach,
plus some vitamins like vitamin B 12.
If you're a.
If you have a.
If you don't have an acidic environment
in your stomach,
you know,
you,
you basically,
if you have to have aesthetic of an
environment than you can't absorb it.
So it's like there's,
there is factors that come into play.
I mean it's complicated and also your
gut bacteria also play a role in what
you're absorbing,
particularly in minerals and.
And so when you take vitamins on an
empty stomach,
if they're not attached to fats and
proteins and carbohydrates,
do they absorb as easily?
It seems that,
wow,
I think there's been research done that
shows that your,
your,
your body doesn't really exactly know
what to do with vitamins and vitamin
form.
If you take them on an empty stomach
with no food attached to them.
I
mean,
I think it depends on what,
if it's a mineral,
what vitamin.
I mean,
I'm not exactly sure,
but some things you're supposed to take
on an empty stomach,
like amino acids,
some amino acids.
You take it on an empty stomach.
I'm not exactly sure about that.
Yeah,
sorry.
So complicated.
Even for Rhonda,
I'm saying that's what I'm saying.
It's like there's so much to know about
what to take away to my friend Dr Mark
Gordon.
Every time I talked to him he fills my
head up with shit that I'm never going
to remember the newest information,
Glutathione and this and that and just,
it's hard.
It's hard to keep up with it.
It is hard.
Things do get complicated and,
and you know,
I,
I don't have all the answers,
but I do.
I do dig pretty deep and try to get some
information out there to people.
That's why these folks who are inclined
to be of the no nonsense group,
uh,
they find it so easy to dismiss this.
I have a friend who's one of those,
you know,
he,
he and I were talking and he goes,
he was like,
he had this smug look on his face,
see that thing they said about vitamins,
they don't work.
And I said,
did you read it?
And he said,
look,
I glossed over it.
I go,
did you fucking read it man?
He goes,
well,
they say vitamins aren't working.
I go to some what they say and then I
showed him what they actually said.
He was like,
get the fuck out of here.
That was the test.
And I go,
yeah,
that was the test.
Old people with heart attacks and they
gave him a pill.
Oh,
they didn't fucking die in a a longer.
They didn't live any longer.
Crazy.
And how do you even measure cognitive
decline in people over 65 with cognitive
decline by a phone call,
by the way isn't real.
Was by phone call,
by a phone call.
So they called them up.
How you feeling?
Okay.
No improvement,
no improvement by a phone call that,
that was.
That was,
that really got me.
Wow.
The specific.
You were reacting to Brian dunning.
Who uh,
what specific things was he saying that
you got so fired up about that you had
to contact me?
Um,
well,
one was that,
that everyone gets there.
It's there.
Yeah.
And the other thing was he was saying
that was the vitamin C thing that was
getting to me too.
He,
he was going on about not needing a
thousand milligrams of vitamin C and
then I looked up some of his stuff and
he was also talking about vitamin C,
napping important or not doing anything
for immune function,
and then he started talking about some
Linus Pauling's.
I can tell you what's wrong with that
guy and it a bunch of things,
but one of the main reasons he does what
he does is that he grew up Mormon,
very strict Mormon background and then
refuted it and now he's an adult and
he's just not gonna take any nonsense.
He grew up with all nonsense and now
he's no nonsense and I have a unique
insight into this because I have some
friends that grew up Mormon and now they
are.
They abandoned it actually in their
forties and it's really interesting
because they're like children in a lot
of ways.
They really
are.
They're the fundamentalists lifestyle
like growing up in a fundamentalist
religion where everything is spelled out
for you and everything is preposterous,
but you've accepted that your whole
life.
You've accepted and you were told not to
question and you're told to follow the
rules of this,
this ideology,
when you get away from that and you need
to try to like figure the world out on
your own.
You're thinking and developed in this
incredibly fucked up way,
the way you make your connections to
things like you have this black and
white sort of connection thing going on
in your head and that's his
fundamentalism translated to a
fundamental skepticism.
So his skepticism is fundamentalism now
he automatically is skeptical of
anything that might require additional
thinking or curiosity or or something
that's going to counter what like a,
a lot of people think like intuitively
think to be true.
Like anything that is a bizarre or
weird.
Anything that like doesn't seem like you
think about someone and then the phone
rings and it's them nonsense nonsense.
Immediately try to stop that.
You know,
he doesn't want anything to be weird.
Can wipe it out from,
from a scientific perspective,
a sciences so often so often gray,
so often not black and white.
I mean there are so many.
There are so many gray areas and there's
so many trade offs.
Trade offs are really another thing.
You know,
where you're,
you're doing something,
you're,
you have this certain Diet and you think
it's like going to give me best
performance,
it's going to give me best cognitive
function and make me live longer.
And it's like,
well there's some trade offs here for
getting all these things and I think
actually a,
that's a really important.
It's not black and white and so people
that have that type of thinking that
have been trained that way and it just,
like you were saying,
you know,
they've,
they've built up these connections
where,
you know,
it is,
it's black and white and if it's not
black it's definitely white.
And it's like that's just not how it,
how it
works.
Their religion becomes just this
skepticism and instead of it being an
open minded objective analysis of what's
at hand and instead until they just want
to stuff it into this skepticism box,
you know,
and immediately debunk things.
People love to debunk things.
It becomes like a badge of honor.
It becomes like they get a checkmark
right in there,
Carlo.
Yeah,
they do.
Well,
I mean,
and when you're talking about science
being gray,
of course oftentimes it's not.
They're not,
but often times it is,
but the reality of the science of
biology is what's really important to
kind of drive home human beings very so
much.
If you get a phone,
okay,
look,
this phone that I have here,
I have a good one.
It works great,
but you could get a same manufacturer,
the same Samsung Galaxy note three.
You can get it from somebody else or
from from a provider.
It's the same components.
It's built the same way.
It weighs the same thing on a scale and
your sucks.
It fucking breaks,
right?
It failed.
Let me give you a perfect example,
so I was talking about Foley,
right?
It's important to make timing,
timing it.
Nucleotide,
it's also important to when you eat
protein and amino acid protein,
it gets converted into homocysteine and
you need.
You need fall late because it's a methyl
donor that then gets methylated and
reconverted back in any because you
don't want too much homocysteine around
and you're in your body because it does
bad things.
Um,
you know,
basically makes protein started
aggregating and it causes vascular
disease and cognitive decline.
And anyways,
10 percent,
no,
actually 10 percent,
40 percent of North Americans have a
polymorphism in a gene called the
methylene tetrahydrofolate reductase,
also known as the mth empty t hfr or the
motherfucker gene basically,
but 40 percent of North Americans have
this polymorphism in this gene that
doesn't make it work correctly.
And so what ends up happening is they
can't read methalate this homocysteine
to convert it back into mining.
So they end up having elevated levels of
homocysteine in your blood and unless
they take more folic acid to sort of
compensate from that,
they're going to have higher levels of
homelessness in their blood and you
know,
which will lead to vascular problems and
cognitive decline.
So yeah,
exactly what the perfect thing.
It's like how much full at I take versus
how much you take.
Or if I'm from Canada,
you know,
who knows,
I mean,
you may have this polymorphism and have
to take,
you know,
five times more fully than I do.
Well,
there's also the variables like how many
people grow up and uh,
you're,
you're in an environment that your
biology is not accustomed to.
People who come from other countries and
then they're in a specific country
that's unique to their biology,
like if they're like what,
what the native Americans experienced
when they were introduced to alcohol,
like this is not something that their
biology was accustomed to and they
really didn't have the ability to deal
with it.
Whereas the Europeans who had been
drinking alcohol for untold years,
they were so accustomed to it,
it was a normal part of their existence
that their bodies have adapted to it.
Whereas the native Americans just
hadn't.
Your body adapts to what it needs to
adapt to.
Your body adapts to its environment.
Your body adapts to its diet.
Your body adapts to the genes that have
been passed down for your ancestor to
ancestor of epigenetics are attached.
It's just,
there's so much.
So for someone to say,
you know,
you don't need this and you do,
or it's like,
it's,
there's so much.
So there's so many variables.
There's so many components.
There's so it's so complicated.
Absolutely.
I mean,
even your gut microbiome like adapts
like within 24 hours,
like if you're eating,
you know,
mostly a protein diet,
the different like interior types that
are in your gut,
you know,
or are there,
they've,
they've shown that people that eat
mostly meat and fat,
there are bacteria,
they have bacteria that's like geared
towards breaking down amino acids,
breaking down lipids,
metabolizing glutamine because you're
given it,
a ton of it.
But people that mostly,
you know,
vegetable,
fiber and carbohydrates,
um,
they have a lot of bacteria that is
involved in amino acid synthesis,
synthesizing these things because
they're not getting as much.
But you can take that person that's had
this longterm diet and give them,
you know,
meat and within 24 hours to start to get
that bacteria that starts to break down
the amino acids.
So your,
your body is very plastic and it does
adapt to different dietary changes.
Do you take probiotics?
Um,
I do.
So,
uh,
yeah,
I do take probiotics.
I'm there.
The whole gut is so,
it's so fascinating.
Um,
I work with someone that's doing a lot
of research on the gut and so,
you know,
I get to learn just just from their
research and reading on my own,
uh,
about the complexities of it,
but it's fascinating like how important
important that bacteria is in our gut
and how important certain types are.
Um,
and how that affects the way we respond
to disease the way we age.
Um,
so it,
you know,
it's,
it's complicated,
it's very complicated.
It is complicated in the,
um,
the environment that's inside your gut.
It actually can contribute to your mood.
It can contribute to depression and
attribute to all,
all sorts of various aspects of your
immune system.
Absolutely info.
Like if you're.
So you know,
if your,
if your gut is,
you know,
if you have basically your innate immune
systems being active down there because
it's unhappy,
uh,
you know,
causing inflammation and things like
having high c reactive protein has been
correlated to depression.
I'm like,
that's actually a biomarker that you
know,
I think can be used with depression is
actually c reactive protein instead of
just this vague kind of,
okay,
I feel this,
I feel that will,
let's measure your c reactive protein
levels.
Okay.
Yeah.
Wow.
They're really high.
Um,
they've even done some studies where
they've,
they've found they've gotten depressed.
Patients found that they had highest
direct protein,
gave him like two grams of EPA.
EPA is the omega three fatty acid that's
important for.
It's like anti-inflammatory as opposed
to Dha,
which is most,
you know,
most of your brain lipitor a Dha,
but two grams of EPA day,
I forgot for how long,
but they lowered their c reactive
protein and helped with her depression.
Um,
so that's pretty profound.
That's very profound.
The,
the connection between the human body
and depression is such a weird one
because for so many folks,
the go to a doctor,
they don't feel good.
The doctor gives them an antidepressant,
they feel better.
And then that's
it.
But there,
there could have been so many other
factors that could have been manipulated
either their diet,
their exercise routines,
hydrating.
I mean,
how many people are fucking just
dehydrated.
They'd feel like,
Shit,
how many people get out of a bad
relationship?
And they feel like,
Shit,
how many people have a bad job?
I mean,
consider what people considered to be a,
you know,
depression.
Uh,
you know,
you're,
you're moody,
you're down the dumps,
you're not,
you're not feeling good,
you're,
you have bad thoughts all the time.
And then consider what's the stimulation
that your brain is receiving everyday
while you driving and traffic in fucking
pollution to a cubicle where you sit and
do shit that you don't want to do all
day.
You get home and then you force feed
yourself,
you know,
some terrible foods because you're
depressed and you're,
you know,
just sort of indulging,
giving yourself some pleasure and
fucking shitty macaroni and cheese or
whatever.
You're stuffing down your face and then
you wonder why you're depressed.
Right?
Right.
Absolutely.
This reminds me of a study where,
um,
they're,
they're using telomere length.
So telomeres are like caps at the end of
your chromosomes that prevent your DNA
from degrading and from getting damaged.
Um,
people often refer to like the tips of
shoelaces like telomeres because they
prevent your shoelaces from fraying.
And these telomere length,
they're really,
they're there when you're young.
They're long,
but each time,
each time your cell divides,
they get shorter and shorter.
Like with each year they're getting
shorter.
I think you lose like 22 nucleotides a
year off your telomeres and it's a
biological marker for aging.
So the shorter your telomeres are a,
you know,
the shorter your life is basically,
if you look at lingers for a young
person versus an old person,
you can see dramatic differences and
stress.
Stress has been correlated with taking
like five years off your team length.
And uh,
the opposite has been true.
Meditation,
they've shown that meditation,
there's actually an enzyme that can
rebuild your telomeres,
but we didn't,
we don't express it in high levels,
it's called telomerase.
But Meditation can actually boost the
expression of telomerase and,
and cause your telomeres to get longer.
So there's really something to that.
You know,
having a more relaxed,
being able to meditate,
not having a lot of stress,
uh,
you know,
affecting the way you age literally.
And we have a biological marker for it.
Um,
yeah,
it's really interesting.
It's another thing,
vitamin D I wanted to,
vitamin D affects the telomere length
also.
Um,
if you,
if you google vitamin D receptor mice
and pull up this image with the mice.
I'm aging mice,
so vitamin D actually does affect the
way we age.
Um,
and they did this study on twins where
they looked at their vitamin D levels,
they measured their vitamin D levels and
they looked at their telomere length and
they found that those twins with the
highest levels of vitamin D also had the
longest telomeres that corresponded to
actually five years being five years
younger,
even though they were twins.
They're same chronological age.
Their team members looked,
they were five years younger if they had
higher levels of Vitamin D.
Wow.
Yeah.
So what do you know anything about t a
65.
I saw sort of a supplement that's
supposed to enhance your telomere
lengths.
I haven't heard of it.
I'm now so,
but vitamin D exercise is another one
that does,
they've done studies showing a,
again in twins,
uh,
those,
that exercise the most actually had two
of them are length that corresponded to
being 10 years younger.
And those,
that exercise sort of like average
compared to those that didn't have an
average of like,
I think four years.
So,
you know,
there's,
there's things that affect the way you
age and we have markers for that
biological markers like Taylor,
my length that,
that proves your lifestyle is indeed,
you know,
affecting the way you age you.
I'd read this telomere study and I'd
seen this with this supplement.
Whoa,
okay.
So let's check this out.
So those two minds on that decay,
these are the same age mouse said the
top panel,
um,
these mice are about four and a half
months old and the one on the left is a
vitamin D receptor knockout,
knockout mouse,
which means it can't respond to vitamin
D.
So it's like,
it's like not having any vitamin D.
If you look at the lower panel,
those are the same age,
four months later.
Look how rapidly that mouse aging
without having vitamin D.
I mean,
there's lots of things going wrong.
I told you that vitamin D's regulating
over a thousand different genes in your
body.
So inflammation,
I mean cognitive function.
I mean there's,
there's a lot of things,
but look at that.
It's pretty striking.
Have you ever thought about going into
business,
like where you provide some sort of a
service where people get tested and then
they develop a specific vitamin
protocols for each individual person?
Yeah,
I know.
We're like my,
my,
my boss and I were,
we talk about that all the time.
Why didn't you do it?
It sounds like I've got this asset where
I can actually measure DNA damage in
your body from your blood and that's
also a marker for age because the older
you are,
the more DNA damage you have and I can
measure that clinically.
So what we're thinking is like giving
people magnesium and seeing if we can,
you know,
less than that damage because there are
DNA repairs working better.
Um,
but that would be really cool.
Another thing would be vitamin D,
uh,
measuring during the vitamin D,
magnesium.
Yeah.
I think there's,
there's a few,
um,
micronutrients that we know of that are
really important for longterm effects.
You know,
like,
like I was saying,
there's often this tradeoff where,
okay,
let's say you,
you've got,
you're getting some vitamin K but you
don't have enough.
In fact,
35 percent of the US population doesn't
get enough.
Vitamin K,
vitamin K is found in plants because
it's a part of their,
they need it for photosynthesis.
So if you're not eating a lot,
a lot of green plants,
then you know,
you're,
you might not be getting enough vitamin
K.
um,
but you know,
vitamin K is often known for being part
of coagulation,
being important to make your blood clot,
right?
And that's an essential function.
So I'm sure any vitamin K you're getting
is going towards that because you want
your blood to clot,
right?
You don't want to bleed out and have a
hemorrhage rate.
But there's other important functions of
vitamin K.
Vitamin K also prevents the
calcification of the arteries.
And so if all your vitamin K is going
towards the proteins that are important
for clotting than the proteins that are
important for not having calcification
in your arteries,
aren't getting any,
and then,
you know,
two,
three decades later and you start to see
this calcification in the arteries and
in fact people that are given Warfarin,
which is a really common,
a drug for inhibiting vitaminK ,
um,
they ended up having problems with
calcification of arteries and stuff.
So,
you know,
there's,
I think there's a lot to understanding
how these micronutrients work that we
don't know yet and you know,
we're starting to try to be able to do
some experiments to understand them.
But the,
the bottom line is that,
you know,
your body's smart and if you don't have
enough of a certain vitamin or mineral,
it's going to,
it's going to shunt it to the one that's
going to help you survive now and help
you reproduce because that's the,
that's what he wants to do.
And these other things like,
you know,
in Dna repairing damaged DNA or you
know,
having to brain work optimally.
You don't have to be that smart to
survive,
you know,
these things,
they probably get the short end,
you know,
so it's kind of like,
it's a vitamins in my mind is sort of
like a long longterm thinking when
you're thinking long term.
It's like,
yeah,
okay,
well I'm not walking around with the
acute deficiencies,
which is what most people think when
they're thinking,
oh,
have enough vitamins and minerals
because I don't have very buried.
I don't have,
you know,
these,
these problems that are severe
deficiencies.
That's like if you're severely
deficient,
you're going to have some symptoms that
you'll notice,
but most of these symptoms you're not
going to notice and they,
they're insidious damage.
It's happening,
you know,
little bit at a time over decades.
It's amazing to me that there,
there's not a lot of these like a center
where you could go and get a full workup
done and they provide you with like a
recipe for your vitamin supplementation
needs
the future.
That is what we want.
Like we want to get it to where we can
just get a finger prick of blood and
will know different proteins.
We can measure that are we know,
are involved in longterm functions
versus a short term functions of these
vitamins and we can say based on,
you know,
having looking at these proteins,
we can say okay,
you need more of this and this and this
vitamin like that's going to be the
future.
It would seem like,
you mean you'd go to the dentist,
the dentist is a normal common thing.
They're everywhere to repair your teeth
and that's such a basic thing,
you know,
but the idea of going to someone who
measures your blood and finds out what
you're lacking in your diet,
that's not
normal.
I think instead of going to a doctor to
try to find a quick fix to get some,
you know,
you're depressed.
So they gave you an Ssri.
Well you know,
we don't know what these,
what the longterm effects of some of
these pharmaceutical drugs are in our
brain.
Like they just had this study that came
out a couple months ago on anti
psychotics,
which they give routinely,
gave people with schizophrenia and they
found that these anti psychotics in a
dose dependent manner cause brain
atrophy.
So.
And they followed these people for 15
years,
this is the first time,
this is the first longterm effect of
Anti psychotics that came out that it
was a really big study and they showed
that these skits,
schizophrenia patients like the higher
the dose of Anti Psychotic,
they were on the more brain atrophy and
you know,
it's like,
so here you are giving these people anti
psychotics and you know,
15 years from now their brain is like
literally it's an atrophying at a rapid
rate.
So that's just a classic example of us
not knowing what some of these long term
effects of some of these pharma logical
drugs that we're doing.
Especially when it comes to the brain.
There's so many feedback loops.
Like if you're,
if you're inhibiting serotonin from
being metabolized or re uptake,
I mean you've got serotonin sitting
around your body,
starts to downregulate serotonin
receptors,
which is how your body responds to Sarah
Tony.
You know,
it's like there's feedback things going
on that I don't think we even
understand.
And you know,
one out of 10 Americans is taking an
Ssri so crazy.
It's crazy.
And I know that they have benefited some
people,
I know people that they,
sure,
but it's,
it's have they exhausted all the other
possible options.
I have a friend who's on an SSRI and he
recently found out that he had been
taking propecia and he recently found
out that propecia actually caused
depression on,
in some people it can cause depression
and some people.
And uh,
he,
he quit,
he quit taking propecia and he's
starting to feel like maybe that was the
cause of the depression the first place.
But he's unnecessarily now.
So now he has to figure out what to do.
You know,
is it,
was it the propecia that caused his
depression?
Was it going to happen anyway?
Is it the SSRI that he needs?
But he also eats a lot of candy and
doesn't take care of his body and
doesn't,
doesn't really exercise.
And you know,
has a shitty diet.
All those things can factor into a,
a low production of Serotonin in your
mind.
All those things can factor into,
you know,
just a clogging of the pathways of
neurotransmitter.
I mean to omega three fatty acids.
Um,
you know,
30 percent of your brain is made up Dha,
which is an omega three fatty acid and
they've shown that actually Dha affects
the way dopamine signaling in your
brain.
So you know,
and in terms of like back to the
schizophrenia,
people with schizophrenia,
you ha,
you make dopamine in this frontal part
of your cortex and the dopamine that you
make there negatively feeds back on,
on this dopamine that you make in the
back part of your brain.
And if you don't have that negative
feedback,
what happens is you start making more in
that back part of your brand,
you start to have like negative things
like hallucinations and paranoia and
things like that.
Yeah.
And so they,
they've shown that Omega three that
they've actually given omega three fatty
acids,
Dha to schizophrenia and shown that it
actually elevates the dopamine and the
frontal part of the brain and helps
regulate some of that negative feedback,
you know.
And so it's like how many people are
getting their eating fish every single
day are getting their omega three fatty
acids for the brain every single day.
I mean,
I know I am,
but I'm pretty much an exception,
you know,
a lot of people that are depressed.
Uh,
like I said,
the EPA is another big thing because
inflammation has been shown to be
correlated with depression.
I'm a huge fan of omega three fatty
acids,
especially in fish oil form.
All right.
Lily,
they make such a huge,
a difference in how my joints feel.
The inflammation,
anti inflammation qualities of them are
really incredible.
It's one of the few things that I always
recommend to anybody if they tell me
they have knee pain or elbow pain or.
Yeah,
I've seen studies on how EPA like giving
even higher doses of EPA to people with
arthritis,
you know,
they're,
they're inhibiting some of the
production of like arachidonic acid and
some of these prostoglandins and things
that are involved in inflammation,
which a lot of people are getting
because they're reading,
you know,
they're getting a lot of omega six fatty
acids too.
So yeah,
it,
I've seen studies where it like it's
been shown to improve it.
You know,
you were looking at this mct oil over
here and you were saying that it's
lacking something.
Oh yeah.
So it's interesting because,
um,
you know,
I,
I actually cook with coconut oil and I,
uh,
at some,
some periods of my life I'd put it in my
coffee,
um,
and uh,
but coconut oil has lower gas.
It's got medium chain triglycerides,
which basically is 12 carbons are less,
lipids are just like long chains of
carbons,
you know,
that are bound together with hydrogens.
So,
um,
the way your body processes long chain
fatty acids is very different from short
chain fatty acids.
The way it,
as long chain fatty acids for one,
I should probably get to that in a
minute.
Okay.
Let me start with a chain fatty acids.
Basically you get your paper and pen
ladies.
Shit's going to go computer then it's,
it's,
it's pretty awesome.
You know,
your,
the way you digest,
it's different.
It goes straight to your portal vein and
it goes to your liver.
Uh,
and then it gets,
goes into the Mitochondria without
having to go through this like transport
system.
And it sort of slightly uncouples the
Mitochondria.
It's thermogenic and you know,
it has all these great benefits for
Mitochondria.
But I'm an interesting thing with Laura
[inaudible] acid is that it's also been
shown to be an appetite suppressant.
Um,
it's through a couple of these different
appetite suppressing hormones.
I think CCK is one,
I can't remember what that stands for,
but you know,
uh,
and it's also antimicrobial,
so it,
it's been shown to kill off Candida
Albicans,
which is like a yeast.
So is 12 carbons and it's a lot of mct
oils
don't have work acid and I don't,
I just can't figure out why they
wouldn't want lower gas had because when
I take coconut oil I'm like,
you know,
lord acids,
like the thing that I'm really excited
about.
So it's not naturally in coconut oil or
coconut oil,
but these mct oils that people put
together some,
a lot of them don't have acid in it
because they'll,
they'll have like less than 12 carbon.
So [inaudible] acid is a 12 carbon,
a medium chain fatty acids and medium
chain triglycerides.
How were they exactly extracted from
coconut oil?
Do you understand the process?
I don't know how they do that and
haven't read about it.
Yeah,
there is some process that allows it to
have this.
Laura and I spell it l a l a U R I c
Lorac acid acid.
It's awesome.
Well,
I want to make sure that on it starts
making mct oil,
mct oil with Lauren.
And what are the benefits of Lorac acid,
again,
specifically for,
for combining it with mct oil or making
sure that it is an mct,
but it's the benefits is one is that
appetite appetite suppressing.
And two,
it's a very strong antimicrobial,
so it's like good for your gut.
It's,
it's killing off like yeast.
It's been shown to kill off know
Albicans Candida Albicans.
Um,
it also has the same thermogenic
properties.
All the eight chain,
a fatty acid tab.
They'll do some mct oils,
have it,
if you've seen it.
A lot of mct now haven't done a survey.
I just look at this one.
I see that it says,
um,
it says a eight carbon,
medium chain triglycerides from coconut
and palm kernel.
To me that says it's not having the 12
carbon,
which is lower acid,
but you know,
I don't know.
Another thing that someone said to me
that they were concerned about was that
it's stored in plastic.
Is there an issue with plastic leaching
chemicals into things like mct oil?
I mean they've shown that certain
chemicals,
you know,
especially in presence of heat can leach
chemicals into whatever is in the
plastic container.
So if like that plastic container sits
in the back seat of your car and you'll
lose your roll down or something along
those lines.
I always try to keep oils at 44 degrees
in the frigerator because it slows that
obviously the oxidation process and all
those,
the heat,
you know,
slowed down.
So ideally though,
which should be stored in it shouldn't
ideally be stored in plastic.
Should it be in a metal?
Should it be in a class?
You know,
it's not a real big concern of mine is I
haven't really put any thought into it
and as long as it's just not allowed to
be exposed to heat and long as you're
reasonably sure that the process from
the storage in the plant,
you know,
the,
the canning,
the bottling,
whatever it is to storage to store that
you're,
you know,
you're not,
it's not sitting out in the sun.
Yeah.
I mean is that something that people
were really concerned with Riley with
plastic bpa.
BPA,
which can leach into water and stuff.
Yeah.
A friend,
his girlfriend went to drink a bottle of
water that was in the car that had,
she had sitting in the back seat.
He's like,
don't drag it,
you know,
like it's a fucking bomb.
Mom did that to be really the same
reason?
Right.
But the plastic,
is that something you.
I mean,
if you have a bottle of water in sitting
in your car and it's a hot day,
should you not drink that bottle of
water because it's been sitting in your
car,
it's probably not going to kill you to
drink it once,
but you know,
I wouldn't do it all the time.
So what happens to the,
the bottle like heats up and then the
plastics leach out into the water and
then it affects hormones in some sort of
a way that,
you know,
I'm not an expert on.
I've done a little bit of reading on
that so I'm not going to claim to be an
expert here.
But yeah,
they've shown that BPA can have some
estrogen mimicking effects and know
that's particularly,
I think a concern,
especially in,
you know,
developing males.
And I'm going to email you this ta 65
stuff because I want you to check it
out.
Please check the number,
but it's about the tele telomere.
Um,
so I'm gonna I'm emailing you that right
now because I,
I had a friend who asked me about it and
I didn't know and I felt like you were
the perfect person to throw this by.
And then laura acid going to with,
like I said,
I don't ever buy mct oil myself.
Like I just use coconut oil.
So is there a benefit of using coconut
oil over mct oil?
Well,
only if the lord,
I think lorich acids in a benefit,
but at the mct oil has lower acid in it.
What's the benefit of mct oil or coconut
oil?
I think they just let not having the
other long chain fatty acids in there.
And that's also in coconut oil would be
those long chain fatty acids.
Beneficial.
It's just fat bad.
So you know,
bad fat,
good fat.
Debatable,
right?
It's debatable.
Yeah,
I think so.
When it comes down to eating a lot of
fat,
you obviously need fat.
I mean fat,
it's important.
Need cholesterol for your brain.
Sixty percent of your brain dry weight
is that your cell membranes here that
the vegans out there,
you need cholesterol,
you need cholesterol.
I say that in my act,
like as a joke about vs that they say
things because they don't get
cholesterol.
Dude,
this is what I'm talking about.
So I've done a little bit of research
and I plan on doing more and actually
coming out with a report on this,
but I'll just talk about what I've done.
So like I planned,
I like to dig,
really dig and make sure I'm
comprehensive,
but some of the,
when you digest fats,
a,
you have to make bile acids and in order
to make bile to basically be able to
absorb them.
And some of these bile acids that you
make when you digest fat are
carcinogenic.
So a d deoxycholic acid dca
is,
uh,
is one that I'm talking about in
particular.
So that's kind of like,
you know,
every time you're eating fat,
your body's making this dca which
damages Dna Damage Dna in your eps,
your epithelial cells lining your
intestine.
Um,
so you know,
that's the sort of a drawback,
but it doesn't mean you should stop
eating fat,
just means you should be aware of your
eating 60 or 70 percent fat diet that
you might want to consider some of these
longterm effects that could rear their
head later in life.
I'm also a eating fat increases igf one
a because igf,
igf one is a growth factor and you
probably have heard of it because in the
fitness community it's sort of like a
downstream mediator or growth hormone
and people are always really excited
about having more igf one because it's,
you know,
helps you bulk on muscle and on and
things like that.
But also it's,
if you have too much of it that you're
making over a lifetime,
it can.
It's a growth,
a signal that tells,
tell cells to overcome the checkpoints I
was talking about earlier where,
where you have these checkpoints where
if you have some damaged DNA that has a
mutation,
then the cell goes,
okay,
it's time to die.
But lots of igf one there says,
oh,
I don't have to die.
I'm gonna keep going.
So you know,
it's highly correlated with cancer.
One Igf,
one being in high doses,
igf one being like what,
like what doses are correlated with
cancer?
Yeah,
that's a great question.
Yeah.
So basically people with cancer,
they have like,
it's just out of here.
So people of gigantism,
they must have an issue with this,
right?
Like that's people that have like they
have to,
like we've,
we've,
we've had a few of those guys in mixed
martial arts that had cancer of the
pituitary gland and then they had the
tumor removed so that they can compete
in the United States.
They were competing overseas and other
and other organizations.
I can pry these to allow these guys to
fight and they would be fucking these
literary giants.
We have a guy in the,
in the UFC right now,
his name is bigfoot Silva,
Antonio bigfoot Silva.
He's,
he has that disease and he had the tumor
removed from his pituitary gland and now
he functions on a normal basis,
but he has to supplement his hormones
because of that.
And is that a similar thing?
I mean,
when you're talking about like high igf
one is that.
Yeah,
well if you're making a lot of growth
hormone from your pituitary,
I mean are they make these pds people
are making a lot of growth hormone?
Yes.
Yeah.
I would assume that me,
that's why they're heads are so big and
their,
their bodies are so distorted.
That's what he looks like now.
That's after the tumor removed.
It's,
you know,
it's,
it's really a fascinating situation
because you look at the guy and it's
quite obvious that his body's gone
haywire.
Skulls enormous.
His hands are enormous.
I mean there's.
You get to see what it looks like.
I mean,
he has all the classic,
very good fighter.
Yeah.
Actually some people that are making
when your,
when your pituitary makes growth hormone
and then stimulates the liver to make
igf one that igf one negatively feeds
back on the pituitary to shut it off,
but people that have that sort of
problem don't have that negative
feedback and they ended up having all
sorts of problems for one,
even though igf one can actually make
your muscle cells insulin sensitive,
which is good growth hormone,
can cause insulin insensitivity in like
your liver.
So they ended up getting,
you know,
having,
insensible insulin,
insensitive liver cells and that's,
that's a major problem with a it with
that.
And aren't there certain amino acids
that you can take before you go to sleep
that will stimulate your body's
production of growth hormone?
I don't know.
I know that I'm take protein and fat,
stimulate the production of igf one.
Um,
but I don't know about certain amino
acids you can take to stimulate growth.
I do know.
So there's,
you know,
growth hormone can be increased from
exercise and also from the sauna.
The Sauna.
Oh yeah,
the sauna.
There's this can increase growth hormone
to massive levels.
The Sauna.
Yeah.
So like,
it's a good thing to go into a sauna
after your workout.
It's a great thing to go into the sauna
after you work out and it's also a good
thing to go in the sauna when you're not
working out if your muscle,
if you're injured because that prevents
a atrophying of muscles.
Yeah.
So definitely.
That's incredible.
I've never heard that before.
My husband and I,
we did some,
I have a report coming out on this,
um,
and probably in a couple of weeks,
so I can't,
a friend of yours or I think his might
publish it on their site,
so I'm not going to mind.
Yeah.
So I'm not going to give Tim Tim
Ferriss.
Oh,
okay.
Cool.
So I'm not,
I don't want to let the cat out of the
bag,
but I did.
My husband and I did a lot of
experimentation with,
with,
uh,
the sauna because we used to live next
door to a why MCA,
which had a sauna and so we would just
go use the sauna like all the time.
And aside from all the research that I,
that I did to write this article,
I'll just talk about my experience and
like when I was injured,
um,
I had some injuries and I couldn't work
out for like a month and I would do the
sauna every day and I did not.
I was not losing my muscle mass.
Like I would've,
um,
if I wasn't injured.
Um,
and also it helped me deal with stress.
and you just know Kayla and stress and
being able to focus.
Yeah.
It's incredible.
And I'm so glad I talked to you today
because I thought the sauna was
nonsense.
No.
Was the other day I went to a spa and I
got a little massage and then they had a
Jacuzzi and a sauna.
I was like,
who goes in that stupid fucking song?
That shit ain't doing nothing.
No hot in there.
It's doing so much.
Why is it doing something?
It was just getting you hot.
I don't understand what's happening.
Yeah,
there's,
there's a lot of things going on.
But like,
uh,
I'll,
I'll tweet you the link.
Please do.
Yeah.
Because email to me and then I'll tweet
it because I'll email it to you could go
right to the abyss.
There's too many people doing.
Sometimes I refresh my feed
and I,
I can't find something that somebody
sent me because it's just too much.
But um,
but the sauna,
it's a fascinating thing to me that
because there's infrared Saunas as well
now.
What's the benefit of that?
Yeah.
So I haven't done a ton of research on
like the differences between just a
normal dry sauna,
which most of the studies that I read,
they're using normal dry dry sauna is
awesome.
Yeah.
Dry Sauna.
I'm just just elevating your core body
temperature basically.
I think,
you know,
the infrared is somehow can heat you up
without some of the damaging effects of
the heat or something.
I'm not exactly sure.
I'll just say that I haven't done a lot
of research on that,
but um,
my,
you can get infrared saunas and just
like put them in your garage.
My inlaws have one in their garage.
We have one that my wife loves and she
climbs into it.
It's like a bag.
It's like a.
it's one of those bags.
I've seen those.
She looks so stupid there with her.
She's got her ipad and she's watching
breaking bad and she's in this fucking
sleeping bag.
It's so ridiculous.
I'm not sure if that's.
I think to get some of the benefits.
You have to kind of push it a little
bit.
I'm not sure if you're gonna.
She's pushing.
She okay.
She gets out of there.
It's like she swam in the ocean.
She said,
oh,
okay.
I've seen those on Amazon,
but I was always curious if that's a
different one than the image shows a
different one.
The one that she has,
she.
She actually lives down in it.
It's so silly looking,
which is.
I thought it was horseshit and food.
It has benefits on the brain.
Think about when you exercise,
you know?
Yeah.
It's like you're elevating your core
body temperature,
which is.
That's exactly what she has.
She clemson that goofy fucking thing and
not expose their head is out.
Yeah.
She,
she needs to get her head in there.
Right.
I'm going to tell her fucking bag over
your head lady.
Well,
I mean it sounds like there's a great
benefit to having one of those things.
Your House if you have room.
Yeah,
totally.
You know,
if you've got a garage,
I,
they don't take up a lot of space.
I did not know.
That's incredible.
I'm so glad I talked to you.
I mean I just went last week to get a
massage and just looked at that stupid
thing.
I was like,
Ugh,
but hot box wish my gym had one.
Like my gym now doesn't have one and I
miss it so much.
Wow.
So how does it stimulate human growth
hormone?
What does it do?
Know how it does.
Um,
but they've measured it,
you know,
they've measured growth hormone after
people have been in the sauna.
And is it a temporary benefit of the
hours after?
It's just like if you were to,
you know,
Jackson growth hormone,
I don't think it lasts more than a
couple of hours either.
Wow.
That is unbelievably fascinating.
It is fascinating.
But there's an interesting,
and I,
I did write a post on this,
this tradeoff on growth hormone and igf
one a tradeoff and that is,
you know,
growth hormone and igf one are,
they're considered really good anabolic
there,
help you bulk on muscle.
They're also good.
It's good for your brain,
you know,
it helps with neurogenesis in your
brain,
but there's a tradeoff.
They've shown that reducing igf
one signaling in lower organisms like
worms and flies and also in mice extends
their lifespan.
So if you take a mouse and you knock out
growth hormone receptor,
it can live 50 percent longer.
Why 50 percent longer,
like huge increase in lifespan.
That doesn't seem to make any sense
because you would think that growth
hormone would be repairing the muscle
tissue,
would you would.
Um,
and,
and so when people actually in people,
people that have polymorphisms in the
igf one receptor that it's associated
with,
like centenarians,
like living to be 92 in 100.
Yeah.
So,
and that's,
that's mostly mediated through.
I'm not getting cancer.
But,
uh,
there,
there is an interesting trade off and I
think that,
uh,
in,
in lower organisms,
the reason is that having that reduced a
insulin signaling helps them deal with
stress like their,
they have an increase in gene expression
for various different genes that are,
you know,
antioxidant genes like jeans,
like glutathione reductase and things
like that.
Um,
and also in genes that help them take
care of proteins and increasing
neurotrophic factors.
I'm not sure if the same benefits are
true in humans and humans.
Mostly.
I think it's a,
they're not getting cancer because
because of having lower igf one,
well,
here's the answer about a amino acids
and a growth hormone.
Apparently there was a,
there's a pub med study on it.
Um,
and they,
they're saying that a specific amino
acids such as Arginine,
lysine and aura,
thien orthodox orphanage can stimulate
growth hormone release when infused
intravenously or administered orally.
A many individuals consume amino acids
before strength training workouts,
believing that this practice accentuates
the exercise induced growth hormone
release,
thereby promoting greater gains in
muscle mass and strength.
That growth growth hormone response to
amino acid administration is a.
has a high degree of inter individual
variability into it.
That's the first time I ever read that.
I'm 46.
I've never read that.
Read that word.
Inter individual.
That's a great word though.
Into it individually for individual
variability and may be altered by
training status,
age,
sex and diet.
Although a parental administration
consistently leads to.
No,
not parental parent.
Turell.
Parenteral.
What does that word?
P A r e n t e r a l what does that word?
Parenteral administration considering
tineal.
Is it?
Is it parents?
Lineal.
Okay.
A R
e n t e r a l any?
Oh No,
it's not per ren tr.
Oh,
let's Google that motherfucker.
Lists Is this golden age of information.
Okay.
Let's look up in dictionary.
Here we go.
It is administered by or occurring
elsewhere in the body than the mouth and
elementary canal.
What's the elementary corral?
God dammit.
Fucking confusing shit.
Okay.
Anyway,
a Blahblahblahblahblah leads to
increased circulating growth hormone,
a concentration oral doses that are
great enough to induce significant
growth hormone release are likely to
cause stomach discomfort.
And diarrhea booms on during exercise
intensity is also a major determinant of
growth hormone release.
Although one study showed that arginine
infusion can heighten the growth hormone
response to exercise,
no studies found that pre exercise oral
amino acid supplementation augments
growth hormone release further,
no appropriately appropriately
conducted.
Scientific Studies found that oral
supplementation with amino acids which
are capable of inducing growth hormone
release before strength training
increases muscle mass and strength to a
greater extent than the strength
training alone.
Hmm.
That's interesting.
How that doesn't.
That seems to be contradictory,
doesn't it?
A little bit.
Yeah.
I.
I'd have to take a look at the study.
If it says that the administration
consistently leads to increasing
circulation of growth hormone
concentration.
World doses that are great enough to
induce significant growth hormone
release are likely to cause stomach
discomfort and diarrhea.
So that means that if you do do that,
you will get more growth hormone.
You will also get diarrhea,
but doesn't that mean it works?
Sounds like it means it works.
If you're looking at growth hormone,
circulating growth hormone as an
endpoint.
Yeah.
So how would they know that's where it
gets confusing,
whether they know that it increases
strength or muscle mass to a greater
extent than the strength training alone,
because a lot of that is variable
individually,
individually as well,
like what have to do a baseline you have
to do with the person itself and do
their.
Do their baseline and then what they
would do without the amino acid and then
do their what they do with it.
So you'd have to compare each person to
their own self.
Yeah.
That's the only way to do it,
right?
Because I've had friends that can just.
I know I have a friend who just can't
fucking pack on muscle.
The guy will lift weights all the time.
He lifts heavy tries,
he can't gain weight.
It gets a little stronger,
but he just can't pack on muscle.
And then I have other friends that they
just look at waits and it will just
grow.
It's crazy.
It's like some people,
they just have that mesomorphic body
structure and they start lifting weights
and their muscles just start expanding
and growing and they just start getting
bigger and other people that they have
that ectomorphic thing going on and they
just can't,
they can't pack it on.
So how would you weight those factors
mean you'd have to know exactly who
you're doing.
You didn't really have to judge it
intensely by the individual alone.
Yeah,
I think that's the best way to do it is
comparing each person to them their
baseline self.
Uh,
you
know,
so that's crazy though.
That growth hormones in mice allow them
to live longer than the converse is
true.
Also,
if you overexert,
if you make a transgenic mouse and
overexpress the growth hormone,
like third expressing lots of it,
they live 50 percent shorter.
Wow.
So it's,
um,
it's a,
it's an interesting.
It's an interesting trade off,
you know,
because oftentimes growth hormones
except associated with where you want
more of it because your growth hormone
levels go down as you age and it causes
muscle atrophy and you know,
your brain,
you know,
brain atrophy and incense too.
So,
um,
it's,
I,
I think it,
it has to do with more of super
physiological levels of growth hormone,
like people that are injecting growth
hormones,
like people that are bodies that are
taking 10 units day that may be a trade
off and they get those big bellies from
it.
Yeah.
So,
you know,
like I said,
if you're,
uh,
when you make growth hormone from your
pituitary and then that stimulates igf
one to be tomato and liver,
that then inhibits the production of
more growth hormone,
him and that,
that feedback is there for a reason.
And so if you just keep injecting it,
you're sort of overcoming that feedback
because,
well,
your body,
you're giving it growth hormone.
It's not making more.
Even though there's igf one there
saying,
shut it off,
you're saying,
no,
I want more.
If there's ever been any studies on
people like bodybuilders that are taking
massive amounts of growth hormone over
long periods of time because,
um,
I read this thing,
I'm Dorian.
Look at that guy.
Oh my God,
that's a.
it's monster.
Isn't that?
Um,
what's his name?
The uh,
Ronnie Coleman.
Yeah.
He's a former Mr Olympia and I think he
probably takes a truck load of
pharmaceutical drugs every day in order
to achieve that physique,
but his stomach,
that's like apparently one of the things
that happens when you take massive
amounts of growth hormone is they
literally bulge out like they're
pregnant.
Wow.
I would love to see someone study that
to see what happens to those guys when
they do that over long for that to be a
really interesting study.
Well,
the bodybuilding industry or the
bodybuilding as a sport is so
fascinating to me because essentially
you're dealing with these chemical
projects because that's what they are.
They're chemical projects.
They're not humans.
I mean,
when you look at a guy like Ronnie
Coleman,
you don't get that big.
A normal guy doesn't get that big.
I mean,
you can get big.
I,
I had a friend who was a total natural
bodybuilder.
There's photos of him in his gut.
That's so crazy.
It's so bizarre.
And you know,
I used to think that that was just big
stomach muscles.
I used to think that he did a lot of
ABS,
so stomach muscles are huge until I
actually read that their organs grow
because of all the hormones at their own
fucking grass.
It looks pregnant.
Look at how pregnant he looks.
It's so strange.
Yeah.
Like I said,
I,
I know I can cause insulin resistance in
the liver.
Well,
people get diabetes
from it,
from over use of growth hormone.
Now the,
the idea that there's a whole support
dedicated to shooting as many chemicals
into your body and turn you into some
freak of science.
That's a strange sport.
Strange.
But you know,
there's,
there's a bit of a tradeoff.
These people are bulking up and they're
lifting lots of weight and know they're
at the trader,
at the expense of a,
you know,
a few years in their life.
So I think
they'll say,
fuck it.
I'd rather be huge.
It'll be huge.
What do you think about,
um,
the,
well that's not a bodybuilder.
What do you think about the studies that
had been done on,
um,
what is that?
Uh,
the,
the thing that happens to cows?
God,
I'm trying to remember the,
the,
the exact function.
There's something that happens to
whippets and it happens to cows.
It's a,
uh,
an accidental aspect of,
of breeding that causes them to
Myostatin inhibitors.
You did,
do you know about all that?
Oh,
great.
I'm going to educate you on the
fantastic.
Something happens.
Pull up miles.
Staten Inhibitor dog.
It's a whippet.
Apparently it occurs like quite
frequently amongst these dogs and they
don't look real.
They look like incredible hulk dogs and
what it is.
Is there something?
Oh,
what does my Stenton do?
I'll tell you right now my own staten
inhibitor dogs it tour dog.
Look at that dog.
That's real.
Holy Crap.
Indeed.
Yeah.
I'm double muscled cattle.
It happens in cows all the time.
A mile stat misfortunes that actually
occasionally takes place in human
beings.
There was a boy in Germany that had,
uh,
an issue,
with,
uh,
a milestone and inhibitors.
Like I'll pull that up.
Boy in Germany,
boy,
Germany and he,
that's a cow that has it.
And um,
they've done it in mice.
And the fascinating thing about them,
I'm inducing this in mice is that the
mice lived longer.
They didn't just live longer.
They were fucking huge.
They were like super mice.
Yeah.
Look at this,
boy,
this is a baby.
Look at the fucking muscles on this kid.
Look at his legs.
Wow.
He looks like an athlete.
You pulled up a mouse study.
What was that?
Yeah,
look at the mice.
Look at them ice.
It's a double muscle mass that lives
twice as long.
That is fascinating.
Yeah.
I'm definitely gonna have to look into
that,
but I still don't know exactly what my
dad does.
Um,
I'll pull up the thing about the mice.
Yeah.
I'm pretty sure they live longer.
This is hard to do while you're actually
trying to do a podcast at the same time.
This is how we rock it here though.
We do it live
because usually,
uh,
you know,
being bulking up like that is associated
with living shorter life.
Yeah.
So that's fascinating.
Um,
I'm here as a Mario Staten.
Yeah.
There's,
um,
apparently there's quite a few studies
that have been done not just on the mice
but also on dogs and cattle to try to
figure this stuff out.
This is fascinating.
If you do a wikipedia,
just like what
the Myostatin I'm okay.
Yeah,
I'll,
I'll just do it on wikipedia here.
Um,
okay.
A abbreviated,
um,
milestone and also known as growth
growth.
Differentiation factor eight of
abbreviated GDF eight is a protein that
in humans is encoded by the m,
s,
t e n gene.
Milestone is a secreted growth
differentiation factor that is a member
of the Tgf Beta protein family that
inhibits muscle differentiation and
growth in the process known as
myogenesis.
Myostatin is produced primarily in
skeletal muscle cells,
circulates in the blood and acts on
muscle tissue by binding a cell bound
receptor called the active in type two
receptor and animals lacking myostatin
or animals treated with substances that
block the activity of Myostatin have
significantly larger muscles and this
could be of economic benefit to the
livestock industry.
However,
these animals require special care and
feeding with ofs,
which offsets the potential economic
advantage.
Look at that boy
so it doesn't say anything about their
lifespan.
Look at that boy's body.
What the fuck is going on there?
That boy is yoked.
I do not want to go to school with that
kid.
Can you imagine a bombed out?
You'd be if you were both 10 and you're
like,
why is billy have a fucking 12 pack?
And I looked like a girl.
It was ridiculous.
I mean,
what does that kid.
I wonder if they're going to allow him
to like wrestle and do athletics.
That seems unfair.
Kids going to take other kids,
just fucking hurl them across the room.
He's going to be the Hawk live fire.
That is fascinating.
I'm going to,
I'm going to have to dig into that
because that's really interesting.
I'd like to understand some of the
mechanisms.
Yeah.
So the gene encoded Myostatin was
discovered in 1997 by geneticists doctor
say Jim Lee and Alexander Mcferrin who
also produced a strain of mutant mice
that lack the gene and there's,
these mice have approximately twice as
much muscle as normal mice.
Incredible.
Yeah.
But I don't know why it happens all the
time and whippets that dog,
that one whip it,
but it does happen in humans.
Really,
really amazing stuff.
Very interesting.
Yeah.
But these,
these sort of things,
um,
it,
it makes you wonder what is that the
mouse is body.
Would they killed it?
They killed it just to show us its
muscle,
but how can we kick off the skin?
Yeah.
How rude could have just taken a
picture.
You don't have to forget fucking crazy.
The,
uh,
the ones who,
the mile staten dogs,
apparently they sucked as runners,
but their appearance with significantly
more muscular.
Yeah.
They still fucking,
you know,
that's the thing about muscle and it's
an issue that comes up and mixed martial
arts all the time and I talk about all
the time in commentary is that you can't
just pack on all that muscle and not
have sort of A.
There's a point of diminishing returns.
It's good to have some muscle,
but the more muscle you have,
the more you have a muscle that's
demanding fuel and you have the same
heart and the lungs.
It's pumping out two more tissue and it
just.
It's just a matter of resources.
You have only a finite amount of oxygen
that you can take in a single breath and
it's distributed through all this
tissue,
all this extra muscle and it.
It really has a significant factor on
people's in endurance,
especially in athletics.
We got that guy.
Is that a real human that's not photo
shopped at all?
I don't know.
It might not be mad what?
There might not be photoshop man.
What they can do today is just really,
really,
really bizarre.
I don't think they live longer.
They don't live long.
That's not a milestone guy.
That's just a guy taking drugs.
I don't think that's a milestone and
guy.
Right.
I don't think there's ever been a human
that's lived.
I think it's a really recent thing.
I Dunno.
Just talking interesting to see what
their mitochondria are doing.
You know,
your Mitochondria or when you're
exercising,
when you're bulking up muscle,
you're inducing mitochondrial
biogenesis.
That's not really,
definitely not real.
Not Real.
Um,
you.
There's been a couple cases where
they've documented children have it in
2004 German boy who was diagnosed with a
mutation in both copies of the milestone
and producing gene,
making him considerably stronger than
his peers.
His mother has a mutation in one copy of
the gene and in then in 2005 and
American boy was diagnosed with
clinically similar condition,
but with somewhat different cause.
His body produces a normal level of
functional milestone,
but because he is stronger and more
muscular than most others his age,
the doctors believed that a defect in
his milestone and receptors prevents his
muscle cells from a responding normally
to mild staten.
And that is what I've heard,
that they are trying to develop a
milestone and inhibitor and that mile
staten producing stat and regulating the
size of your muscle tissue.
If they could come up with a mile stat
inhibitor,
it would increase the size of your
muscles.
I don't know if that's a good thing.
I mean it doesn't seem like it as well.
It seems like it would help some people
if they're,
if they have like wasting disease or
something along those lines.
But it's going to be really interesting
though that when they start coming up
with like gene doping for that and they
start giving it to wrestlers or football
players or things along those lines
because it seems like anything that
affects the body so significantly as you
see those mice or those,
those dogs,
someone's going to take that shit.
There is some online.
Absolutely.
There's a guy with lining up right now
with is we willie and his pants and he's
ready to just shoot that in there and
make up for everything and there's a
trade off.
But you know,
he cares.
Well.
Do you follow genetic manipulation or
studies on genetic manipulation and the
potential for what they're,
where they're figuring out these days
because it,
it seems incredible and it seems that
the future is going to be so bizarre
when you deal with the idea that,
you know,
the exponential increase in the uh,
ability to,
to change things and to alter the human
body is just going to continue as long
as society allows this research to
continue as long as society allows,
you know,
long as we don't blow ourselves up.
This work is gonna continue to go on,
there's going to be more breakthroughs.
There's going to be more significant
increases in the capacity for change and
know who knows what the fuck is going to
be like just a decade,
two decades from now.
Yeah.
I'd like to see some,
um,
we've already made some major advances
in the stem cell research,
which to me is one of the most
important,
you know,
because if you can,
if we can get to the point where we can
replace our damaged motor neurons or you
know,
make sure we're not getting Parkinson's
disease.
I mean,
I think that's a huge,
uh,
you know,
that's,
that's a huge thing in,
in helping us extend the quality of our
life.
Um,
you know,
because you don't want an urge to
interrupt disease.
No,
that's,
that's something that you don't,
I mean there's certain things you can do
and you're in your lifestyle to try to
not get one.
Uh,
but it'd be,
it'd be pretty sweet to have some
genetic breakthroughs in these stem cell
therapies and,
and we're making progress.
We just,
we're not there yet.
I would like to see a study on someone
who follows the exact protocol that
science that someone like you would
prescribe to him or her and that they do
it over a long period of time and they
have a twin that doesn't.
Right.
You know,
they do.
And they do some of those studies where
they're looking at specific things like
specific vitamins or exercise or things
like that.
But a long term study where you're
looking at multiple changes.
I would love to see that as well.
Yeah.
One person drinks,
one person doesn't one person's fault.
They did this study they did in monkeys,
you know,
and it was like a 27 year experiment I
think,
um,
where they,
so caloric restriction is known to
extend lifespan in lower organisms and
also in this monkey monkeys they did,
um,
where if you give a,
give a monkey 30 percent food than it
would normally eat.
So you basically let the monkey decide
what it would eat and then you say,
okay,
I'm going to,
I'm going to give them 30 percent less
of that,
you know,
every day.
And they did this for like 27 years.
Um,
can you pull it?
Can you do a google search on caloric
restriction monkeys?
And just like pull up the image that
compares them a big impact.
So it has a huge impact on the way they
age these monkeys are.
They get age related diseases,
less cardiovascular disease.
Last cancer brain atrophy,
nurse of diseases less with a
significantly smaller.
I'm the monkeys were not significantly
smaller,
but they looked significantly better.
So it's cruises worked better.
Yeah.
Okay.
There's one picture,
I think there's one where they're like
for Pam was on one of the writers obese
though.
Okay.
Yeah,
there had picked up that one with the
four panel.
Yeah,
that one.
So yeah,
these monkeys are actually the same age
here and that monkey on the left a
monkeys.
It's in its old age 27 and a half years
and it's had a normal day.
Like it's just eaten what its normal
amount of food and that monkey on the
right has been given 30 percent less
food everyday for like it's 27 point
five years.
I mean it's incredible.
It's incredible.
Way Better.
I mean you can just tell by the way,
looks he's aging better,
but he also seemed body.
It's actually he looks more muscular.
Yeah.
So it's.
He looks like he's lost less muscle,
less much muscle atrophy.
I mean,
so what they found,
they've done like these gene profiling
expression arrays where they can measure
like thousands of different genes at
once and they've seen that caloric
restricting actually change the
expression in like thousands of genes.
So it helps like genes that are involved
in protein degradation,
protein synthesis,
like all these things are changed and
these caloric restriction monkeys,
genes that are involved in like,
you know,
growth factors in the brain,
those are upregulated at inflammatory
genes are downregulated.
So it's like,
you know,
27 years left less have constant
inflammation going on.
And so there's,
it's very interesting how,
and there's a couple of theories as to
why these monkeys age better or why
calorie restriction,
you know,
is can,
can help the way you age.
Um,
and one of the big theories out there is
that this,
they're sort of like a hormetic
response.
So hormesis is basically where you have
like a low level of stress,
like a little bit of stress,
and that stress then helps you,
uh,
changes the expression of genes that are
involved in stress.
And so you basically can then deal with
stress later.
So it's Kinda like conditioning your
body to deal with stress by giving it a
little bit of stress.
Um,
and this is kind of the same thing with
a lot of like xenobiotics like plant,
polyphenols,
catechins,
these sorts of things.
That's how they work.
They actually,
they induced this hormetic response
where they increase the expression of
stress resistant genes that we have in
our body that help us deal with protein
stress with,
you know,
reactive oxygen,
species,
stress with all this different types of
stress.
And because we're increasing the
expression of those genes were dealing
with stress better every single know
every single day in that,
in that case,
you know,
for 27 years.
Um,
and so it's very,
uh,
this whole idea of hormesis is very
interesting where you're sort of giving
your body a little bit of stress,
like exercise is stress and it's a
little bit of stress and it does the
same thing.
But that whole field of epigenetics is
just so fascinating how you know,
things that you eat,
what you do can actually change the
expression of genes.
And this actually affects the way you
age.
And really what's interesting,
not only does it affect the way you age,
it affects the way your children that
you haven't had yet age,
you know,
so are you familiar with what
epigenetics is?
Okay.
So basically it's explaining it for
people that might not be.
So epigenetics is basically causing a
change in your and your gene.
Are there factors that sit on top of
your genes?
Basically to give you a very simplistic
topical view,
they sit on top of your jeans and like
methyl groups are acetylation groups and
they turn,
they activate your genes.
Then when they activate your genes,
they turn them on.
And so the genes become what's called
express.
They're expressing the genes when they
are expressing the genes,
they're doing what they're supposed to
do and other factors can sit on top of
them and turn them off.
And even though the gene is still there,
it's like it's not there because it's,
it's not being expressed.
But these epigenetic factors don't
actually alter the DNA nucleotide
sequence like a mutation would.
So that's the difference.
And mutation changes the DNA nucleotide
sequence,
epigenetic factor.
This thing can be modulated.
And it doesn't change the sequence,
it just,
it changes how much of that gene is
being active or not active.
And,
and these epigenetic marks are regulated
by what we eat,
by stress,
by exercise,
by all these various factors in our
environment.
Um,
and so that's,
that's one study where they've changed
in gene expression from calorie
restriction.
They've done.
Uh,
and I heard someone on your podcast,
I talk about this study.
I'm the sweetest Swedish study that was,
there's been a few of them that have
been done,
um,
where in Sweden they keep like extensive
records of people's,
um,
you know,
there,
there's records of what they eat,
what diseases they've had throughout
their life,
when they were born and if they were
depressed,
what they died of.
I mean,
they're very extensive records on people
and also they have extensive like
agricultural records.
So they can say like,
during this part of,
you know,
the country at this time of the year
there was a lot of famine or there was a
lot of,
you know,
there was a great crop harvest.
And so particularly this northern part
of Sweden called nor buttons.
Sweden,
back in,
I think it was like the 18 hundreds,
they looked back,
uh,
during this period of time for whatever
reason,
it was hard to get in and out of there.
And so people really dependent on the
crops that were there.
So if there was good a lot of crops and
it was good harvest,
people really gorge themselves,
the eight they overeat.
And if people,
if the harvest was bad,
um,
there was a famine and people really,
they sort of are calorie restricted.
They,
they basically didn't get to eat as
much.
And so a lot of these Swedish sciences
have looked.
Scientists decided to look back and see,
well what effects did that have on
future generations?
So it's Kinda like is there a
transgenerational epigenetic effect on
longevity?
So let's look at these people that grew
up during the famine versus feast years
and let's look at their children and
their grandchildren,
see what diseases they had or what,
how long they lived.
And you know,
it's not like incredibly,
it's not like a controlled study.
I mean,
it's very correlative and there's a lot
of factors missing,
but it's still very interesting.
Um,
what they found is that,
um,
males that were between the ages of nine
and 12,
and if they lived during the,
if they were nine and 12 during the
famine years,
they had children and grandchildren that
lived on average about seven years
longer than the grandchildren of those
that grew up during the,
the abundance years and when they
corrected for socioeconomic status,
meaning,
okay,
rich people kind of well,
no matter what,
when you correct for that,
when you have people from the same
socioeconomic status,
those,
those are grandchildren of the men that
were between the ages of nine to 12
during the famine,
years lived 32 years longer,
which is like crazy,
a increase in lifespan.
And they also,
they had more studies coming out where
those grandchildren had were one fourth
less likely to get a type two diabetes
and also cardiovascular diseases.
So I was like,
why?
Why do you have to be between the age of
nine and 12 and a male to,
you know,
why growing up during that part of the
famine,
how does that affect your,
your grandchildren's lifespan?
And we can't,
we can't really tell you why,
but there's some sort of theories as to
why.
And uh,
during that time period,
there's something,
you know,
your pre pubescent,
right?
Right before you actually get,
get that growth spurt and uh,
the,
they think there's something to do with
the sperm DNA that gets changed.
A little bit of stress,
that little bit of Hormesis Po possibly.
Um,
a little bit of stress changes the
expression in your genes,
sperm genes and that gets passed on.
So it's fascinating.
I'm so much to learn still about the
human body.
I feel like we're in a great time in
comparison to other civilizations when
you look back and what they used to do
for medicine,
what we're aware of now,
but I feel like 100 years now they're
going to be laughing at us,
right?
Yeah.
No,
it's um,
you know,
I think the future is preventative
medicine,
you know,
and there's gonna be some breakthroughs
eventually and things like stem cell
therapy,
but I think diet,
nutrition and these things are what we
can do now.
That's what we can do now we have
control over and it absolutely has been
shown to affect the way we age period.
And so we know this.
So let's,
let's implement it.
Let's educate people.
Let's do it,
you know,
as opposed to waiting around for some
scientific breakthrough that may or may
not happen in your child's,
you know,
during your child's lifetime.
So there,
there's just no telling you know what's
going to happen.
But we do know right now that we can
control certain things,
you know,
and the way we age through,
through our diet and our lifestyle.
And,
and that's,
that's what we need to start
focusing on.
Um,
I want to mention another really cool
thing about this epigenetic.
Turn the microphone a little bit more
towards you.
It'd be a little bit.
Sorry.
Yeah.
All right,
so this,
I'm back to the epigenetics.
A study,
something even as complex like learning
and memory can be modulated by,
by your environment.
And this was a mouse study where they
took mice that were transgenically a
modulator to get neurodegenerative
disease.
And uh,
so they put these mice usually when we
work with mice,
they're in this cage has bedding,
it has some food and water and that's
about it.
There's not a lot of stimulation,
a lot of exercise.
Um,
it's really kind of sad,
but they took these mice and they put
them in what we call an enriched
environment.
So they give them all these toys that
stimulated various regions in their
brain,
like the cognitive region,
motor region,
um,
Somata sensory regions.
And what they found was that these mice
scored better on learning and memory
tests.
And not only did they score better on
learning memory tests,
they,
they had increased the expression of a
gene that's involved in longterm
potentiation.
Longterm potentiation is that signal
that you're making when you're learning.
You need to remember things,
you know.
But the really interesting thing about
this study was that these mice that were
genetically engineered to get
neurodegenerative disease had offspring,
mice that were also genetically
engineered to get an urgent or disease,
but we're not put in an enriched
environment.
So they were putting that boring cage
where they had no stimulation,
but they had still increased that
longterm potentiation gene,
that epigenetic factor was passed on.
Um,
in this case it was through the egg,
through the female line to the offspring
mice,
which had the same learning memory
benefits even though they didn't really,
they weren't exposed to that
environment.
So I mean,
just,
just having cognitive stimulation,
just using your brain more and
exercising more can affect the
expression of your genes.
And that can actually get passed on.
It is so fascinating.
One of the reasons why athletes tend to
develop athletes for children is that
one of the reasons we're really
intelligent people tend to have
intelligent children,
like is possibly not just environmental
and educational,
but epigenetics as well.
Right.
I mean certainly in the environment
plays a component and those things.
But,
you know,
the epigenetics,
we're just,
we're just sort of starting to
understand epigenetics and how it works
and it's complicated.
It's not easy to study,
but,
you know,
it's,
yeah,
there's certainly a role for,
for epigentics and that.
So it's,
it's fascinating.
So fascinating.
It's very fascinating and it's so
fascinating when you stop and think
about how much we're going to learn,
you know,
what we know now and what we're going to
learn.
It's incredible.
It's just incredible.
You just think of the potential for
reengineering the human body.
I mean,
that's,
it seems like we're going to be able to
do all these things we're doing to mice,
given them double muscles,
making them fucking smarter,
where we're going to be able to do that
to people.
We're going to make a doctor Manhattan
number from that movie,
the watchman.
We're going to make a document and going
to happen.
There's going to be a guy one day that's
omnipresent super being that,
uh,
that becomes a God.
We're going to fuck up and make a god.
You know,
I'm,
I'm trying to,
I try to do what I can to make myself
work better and you know,
cognitive wise and you know,
and also tried to basically age better
so you know,
it's,
it's certainly like we,
we can do things like now.
Um,
but just yeah,
like you were saying,
genetically changing someone's like
literally like,
you know,
making,
making someone's muscle grow like that
by like giving them an inhibitor of this
certain milestone and receptor.
I mean that's like hardcore stuff that,
you know,
we don't really know what the effects
are going to be doing.
Things like that.
Longterm comes down army of super
beings.
That's what it's going to be.
There's Dr Manhattan,
that's what we're going to have.
That guy's going to be running shit 100
years.
That's our new president,
you know,
as long as he's really intelligent,
let's make his brain like super awesome.
Dr Manhattan was really intelligent,
unfortunately to intelligent,
so intelligent that he sorta like
factored in a lot of things like,
well,
you know,
people live,
people die,
you no remorse and guilt and all these
things are really just byproducts of
human culture and our correlation to,
you know,
a cause and effect and our reactions to
each other.
They mean it.
It took away all the joy and fun.
The zest of life.
You've got a little bit too intelligent.
That problem's a problem.
Absolutely.
I would make people just smart enough,
but not too smart.
Whether they realize what's the fucking
point.
You live,
you die.
You're just a finite organism and even
if you live forever,
the planet doesn't live forever.
So what do you.
What are you going to do here?
Yeah,
yeah.
I mean,
I've had conversations with really
intelligent people.
They talk about the futility of life and
I'm like,
you probably might be.
You're too fucking smart and you think
it too much,
or maybe not even too smart,
but you're thinking too much about stuff
that really you can't control and maybe
you got to be smart enough to realize
that this is all silly.
Yeah.
Thinking about the things you can't
control sometimes that that overlap.
Like I get these,
what I call it,
OCD spikes where it.
If I'm driving on the highway,
I start to imagine all the possibilities
that can happen.
Like all the things that can happen with
all the cars and it liked those.
There's moments where it's so
overwhelming where I just can't do.
I can't drive like it's too much.
It's like somebody's husband ends up
driving me around a lot on the freeway
drive.
True story and it's like,
so what I often do is I like to live
five minutes from where I work.
That way I don't ever have to get on the
highway because I don't have to think
about all the things that can happen.
When I'm on the highway.
It's,
wow,
you're too smart to drive.
Well,
I don't know if it's that I sometimes
obsess over what I can't control and the
fact that there's like all these people
and I'm like,
they're doing all these things and all
this could happen and all these
possibilities and you know,
then it's like,
okay,
it's like overload.
I had a moment when my
first daughter was born,
where when I was in the hospital in the,
the moment she came out of the box,
I was thinking like how many different
people are being born right now
simultaneously all around the world.
And if you could see that on a giant
screen,
I mean it would look like an invasion of
babies.
If you could see the millions of people,
no doubt being born all over the world
at the same moment,
just,
ah,
just shooting out of Vaginas,
Bang,
Bang.
Just,
it would be so in the.
I got over it,
I got over it.
Glad we have that ability to get out
some of that stuff because yeah,
it's overwhelming.
It's overwhelming,
it's very overwhelming.
It's sort of the issue with,
um,
what,
what one of the main issues with paying
attention too much to bad things in the
news,
and I've talked about this many times,
I think we have a real problem with
digesting 7 billion people's worth of
problems because anytime something
spectacular or horrific comes up from
all over the world,
we get it and we absorb it and it sort
of alters our idea of what the world is.
Oh,
the world is a scary place and it's
filled with evil.
The really the numbers are pretty
against that.
The numbers,
like throughout your day,
you experience very little violence
throughout your day.
You experienced very little horrific
crime.
It's very,
very rare in most parts of America,
unless you live in a terrible
neighborhood to experience the kind of
shit that you see on your news feed or
your twitter feed all day everyday.
It's not an accurate expression because
it's based on such an insane number that
you're not supposed to be correlated.
You're not supposed to be looking at a 7
billion people number,
supposed to be looking at a tribe of 150
people.
I mean,
that's what our brain that's with the
Dunbar's number is,
that's,
you know,
we don't,
we don't really know what the fuck to do
with 7 billion people's worth of
information.
So we become these paranoid messes when
we start thinking about all this
horrible shit that's happening.
But you're talking about a fucking
planet worth.
I mean literally a planet worth of
information now.
And it's like that's the same sort of
thing.
This just freaking out.
Thinking about all the variables that
you can control.
We were not designed for that.
Is it possible that we will,
that the epigenetics of living in this
life will alter our genes and our
expression of our genes so that we can
accept this kind of information?
Is that something that we're gonna like
will start to adapt?
Yeah,
yeah,
absolutely.
I mean,
they've shown that stress does
epigenetically changed expression of our
genes.
So tabloids are fucking us up,
right?
You know,
I don't listen to tabloids,
but uh,
yeah,
I'm sure there are even just
fearmongering,
you know,
just going on at the Alex Jones website,
just paying attention to all these
people that are doom and gloom,
new world order.
They're fucking chem trails.
They're putting caskets out in the fema
camps and getting ready to mass kill
people.
It is,
it's definitely changing the expression
of your genes shed stress distress is
doing something bad shit and it's also
shortening your telomeres don't need
that.
But I got a problem too.
I fucking eat like a pig.
That's a real problem on a die young.
I,
I eat enough for like two or three
people.
Like what do you eat?
I eat everything.
I eat whatever's in front of whatever
you want.
I've got a problem.
I work out a lot and because of that I'm
always hungry but I eat a lot.
I eat so much sometimes waitresses don't
believe me.
Like when we go,
like after shows,
like if we'll do like two or three shows
a night,
I'll order two entrees and then a bunch
of appetizers and I've had people say
that's too much.
Oh,
that's a wager soul.
Say That's too much.
Like just keep it coming.
Don't worry about it.
I'm putting it down.
Wow.
That's a lot of food.
Two entrees regularly.
Two entrees.
And that's after having two other meals
usually.
Yeah.
But it's just if I'm working out,
if I'm working out in our work at the
same time,
two things happened in the day,
my appetite is just insane.
It just,
it's a pit that just can't be filled.
Well,
I mean your body needs the uh,
I'm gonna die younger.
I'm not going to be like the cool older
mouse,
cool older monkey that's got his shit
together.
Fuck it.
Take it down a notch that they're trying
to do some of these caloric restriction
studies in humans to see,
you know,
what if it's the same,
if it's the same and you know,
of course doing the longevity studies
going to take forever.
So that's hard.
So they're doing kind of like a year
long study and looking at specific end
points and they're finding some things
are a little different actually from,
from,
from the mice and monkeys.
All I'm sure there's gotta be a
difference between monkeys and human
beings are pretty profound difference as
far as what our needs are nutritionally.
And also the,
the,
uh,
the idea of stress because we can sort
of conceptualize stress in a way that
they can mean they're dealing with the
immediate threats only.
They're not conceptualizing,
man,
I'm not going to live forever.
Man.
Asteroid hits me,
man.
That's not.
It's not there.
I don't want to die of cancer.
Hurt.
Oh Man,
what if my wife's cheating on me?
He didn't.
They're not thinking about any of these
things.
What if I get fired?
They're not thinking about any of these
things.
They don't have anything other than
immediate concerns,
which is kind of what we're designed
for.
Right?
I mean,
when you look at the genes of human
beings and the amount of time that we've
been in this particular type of a
society and the amount of time that
we've been essentially hunter gatherers
and it's,
there's no comparison.
We have a long stretch of time where we
were just living a very specific way and
then over the last couple of hundred
years things radically shifted.
It's very strange and new direction and
then we find ourselves where we are now
from the invention of the printing press
to the fucking twitter feed.
Oh,
three printers freaked me out,
man.
People are just going to start making
guns.
They're actually.
Nasa was funding a study.
I'm trying to three d print,
non living biomolecules like wood chips
and like dental enamel and I know it's
kind of cool.
Very cool.
Yeah.
So,
so that's,
that's Kinda Nasa is funding some really
cool stuff and other really cool study I
saw recently where they took,
they took cancer cells and they cultured
them in space because they wanted to see
if space could epigenetically change the
expression of genes and if this would
have any effect.
And they found it,
did that gravity,
did it affect actually genes that are
involved in metastasis and when you kill
culture,
these cells in space,
it downregulates genes involved in
metastasis and those cancer cells become
less aggressive.
So then they took these cells and like,
okay,
well there's a million different things
that could be happening in space.
Is it the gravity or is it like cosmo
raise or something?
And so they like culture them in the
centrifuge,
them meaning they spin and they spun on
a certain rotation per minute to like
copy or mimic this microgravity.
And they had,
they found the same effect.
So literally like the gravity change,
the expression of these genes involved
in metastasis.
Uh,
so yeah,
so if you have cancer or maybe go to
squarespace or the very top of a
mountain,
I'm just wondering where they're going
to go with that next.
I mean,
it's like,
okay,
well that's interesting finding,
but so what do we do?
Are we going to rotate for,
you know,
if you have cancer,
it's,
it's just,
uh,
some interesting.
Well then there's also the issue where
you can't really go to space for very
long anyway because if you do go to
space,
your body doesn't really.
The body's really not designed to be in
a zero gravity environment.
We had a Dr Chris,
our commander Chris Hadfield on the
podcast,
one of the guys.
How long did he go to space for?
One hundred 60,
six days or something crazy like that,
and he came back and he was describing
the horrific moments where he first
stepped out of the,
the,
the pot or whatever it is that you
landon and was walking on the ground for
the first time getting nauseous and
throwing up and your body's just so not
used to being in gravity and standing on
the ground.
You just been floating around for so
long that your body's just totally
baffled and he said it was horrific.
I,
I thought it had been a wonderful
experience.
Like what was it like when you finally
touched them?
The ground you'd been up in space for so
long.
He's like,
it is unbelievably awful.
Wow.
Yeah.
Your,
your,
your body's just in chaos.
It doesn't know what you've been doing
this whole time.
Yeah,
it's pretty crazy.
The body's crazy.
It is very crazy and it's very.
It does adapt.
I mean there's things that are.
No,
it does adapt.
It's so endlessly fascinating.
When you find out what has been learned
about the body,
how many studies have been done,
what,
what information is out there and then
yet how much we need to learn,
how there is to know how much there is
to discover.
It's just we're not even close.
Not even close.
We're just learning,
which is again,
why it's so infuriating when you read,
you know,
vitamins don't work.
Case closed.
Fuck you.
No,
it's not.
It's not that simple.
A lot of vitamins do work and there's
been a lot of studies showing that they
work well.
It's not an accident that we've isolated
vitamin C,
it's not an accident that we know that
vitamin B 12 gives you energy.
I mean these are.
This is science that created all this,
so all these no nonsense people.
There is a lot of fuckery when it comes
to vitamins.
There's a lot of fuckery when it comes
to nutrition,
you,
you're always reading about some,
you know,
false claims that you know,
this company has or that company has,
are these pills.
However though you're,
you,
we hear about things all the time and it
comes to nutrition and supplementation,
especially when it comes to athletics,
supplementation,
things that are purported to deliver,
you know,
amazing muscle growth or you know,
they've found that a lot of those things
that are purported to give muscle growth
or erection pills.
Here's a perfect example.
You know what those things are.
When there's a cialis and Viagra,
they just sell that.
They sell it as some herbal supplement,
but they put in pharmaceutical drugs.
They get,
they buy that shit in bulk and they sell
it and it actually does work,
but their pharmaceutical drugs,
but because of the fact that the
restrictions are so small and the band
or the punishment of doing that is so
small.
We had a aubrey marcus in from on it who
was describing the whole process of one.
One of these companies gets caught
selling Viagra as one of these herbal
sexual stimulants.
They just get a,
like a little fine.
So they changed the name,
they open up and under a different
company and go right back at it and they
just have the rocket dick or whatever
the fuck they call it.
I mean,
there was a study that
it came out not long ago.
They showed that like 70 percent of like
herbal supplements on the market aren't,
aren't actually what you think they are.
So in a lot of cases people are just
putting some other plane in there and
it's like,
you think you're getting,
you know,
Achalasia or you know,
and it's like some other crap.
And so that's like,
I think there's a whole,
you know,
uh,
an opening for people to actually do
like some DNA barcoding where you can
actually test,
you know,
what's in a supplement and start a
company where it's like,
I've,
I've tested these supplements and
they're actually what they're saying
they're supposed to be,
you know,
because it's like you've got a huge
problem when people are trying to buy
certain supplements.
And then they're not even getting what
they think their body,
regardless of whether or not there's any
science to back up with what they think
they're buying.
Is he doing anything?
I mean the point is they should,
they should be getting what they think
they're getting.
And then of course there's a huge issue
of homeopathic cures,
which are mostly nonsense.
There's a huge homeopathic industry.
There's essentially selling you sugar,
you total bullshit.
They've.
There was a recent study on homeopathic
the,
the actual ingredients and some
homeopathic cures and
a lot of it was sugar.
So like they're literally selling sugar
pills.
Yeah.
There's a difference between,
you know,
not having certain vitamins and minerals
and fatty acids in your diet and things
that can,
you know,
if it affects your immune system and
affects cognitive function,
it affects all these different things.
And then taking all this other crap that
I don't know,
people like the I the idea of some
exotic thing isolated from somewhere and
it's like,
oh,
it does this because it's exotic and you
know,
the reality is,
is people,
they should be focusing on what they're
not getting.
That's essential for,
you know,
things that we know that's essential for
the proteins in their body to work.
Um,
and so that a lot of that homeopathic
stuff,
it gets mixed in with the vitamins and
minerals to.
And that's really irritating because
it's really.
There are two different things.
Yeah.
Nutrition and homeopathic.
There's a lot of nonsense if you're
interested in that.
Just Google a homeopathic medicine,
sugar pills and there's all of studies,
there's a lot of different stuff on,
on sugar pills actually.
They've shown they've done a placebo
effects studies using sugar pill pills,
um,
where they've published.
They've given someone a placebo.
I mean the whole point of the study was
not for the person conducting it to not
know who had the placebo.
It was,
okay,
let's see if the placebo effect is real.
And it absolutely is real.
I mean there are people,
people,
if they think they're getting something,
they will experience something,
you know,
and it's real to them.
And then actually they,
they don't get sick as much or they feel
better,
you know.
So there's,
there's definitely something to be said
for a sugar pill.
And maybe that's part of the success of
things like homeopathy.
That's really confusing,
isn't it?
The placebo effect is absolutely
fascinating that you can send the mind a
signal or,
or instill it in a mind by taking a pill
and then the mind believes that medicine
is there and then conducts business as
if this new found healing property
exists.
Yeah.
No.
And it's,
it is real.
The placebo effect is real,
but we don't know why.
Right.
I mean,
I haven't really done a ton of research
and understanding why,
but yeah,
it's,
it's interesting how your brain can,
you know,
make your,
make yourself think that something's
working and you actually can force
yourself to be healthier.
I mean,
so it's fascinating.
It is very,
very,
very fascinating.
Endlessly,
endlessly.
So,
I mean,
the human being is like a human body is
to me essentially like the most
incredibly complex computer ever.
And we don't have a guidebook for it
right now.
We're just talking about the physical
aspects of it.
Forget about managing your mind,
your thought process,
which also can lead to a lot of ailments
and incorrect thinking and thinking
apps.
I mean,
when I started getting,
when I started researching these studies
on the effects of,
you know,
depleting trip to fan from your brain
and how like normal people all of a
sudden become like,
impulsive,
like,
you know,
violence and impulsive behaviors and
recidivism.
So they,
like,
they'll do these tests were they
punished for doing something wrong and
they'll.
And they'll keep repeating the same
thing.
I mean,
I was like,
I can't believe
you can change someone's behavior by
depleting trip to fan.
Like that's,
that was really,
you know,
amazing to me.
And,
and the way that nutrition affects your
brain function in general and behavior
is really interesting to me because it
suggests that we have to some degree,
some control over our cognitive function
behavior.
And I think that we should be optimizing
that as much as we can to,
you know,
perform better to have better cognitive
skills and to also better society by
behaving better.
You know,
so,
you know,
they've,
they've done studies with like school
children where they've giving them like
omega three fatty acids and
multivitamins and it's absolutely,
you know,
how effected their,
their,
um,
Iq scores in some cases by like dramatic
effects and even affected juvenile
delinquency and juvenile.
Yeah,
it's effected,
effected juvenile delinquency.
There's been studies showing that giving
these people a multivitamin and omega
three fatty acids.
So it's hard to pinpoint what
specifically in it,
but I think it's a combination of
everything because these pathways are
all working together,
but it's affecting their.
What I think is happening is,
you know,
it's also affecting their serotonin and
so they're,
you know,
they're not,
they're not as impulsive,
they're there,
you know,
it's more like long term thinking there.
It's,
it's absolutely fascinating that you can
actually,
through nutrition affects someone's
behavior.
There was another study where they had
given prisoners omega three fatty acids
and it affected their aggressive
outbursts.
Um,
you know,
because that's another,
that's a whole other topic.
You know,
you've got a population of people that's
incarcerated and knows what they're
getting fed,
probably deficient in multiple
micronutrients,
including omega three fatty acids and
Vitamin D.
Guy on recently is kid war machines,
have a MMA fighter,
John Copa neighbors,
his real name war machines,
his fighting name,
pretty cute,
and he was talking about a year that he
did in prison where they.
They gave him 1500 calories a day and it
was horrible nutrition and just how his
body just felt like it was wasting away
because of it.
Yeah.
See,
this is,
I would like to see,
you know,
we're spending money to keep people in
prison.
You know what,
why not give them,
give their brain the proper nutrients
they need to try to heal itself,
to try to make it work better.
You know,
you're talking silly because you're
talking about a person wants to fix
people.
They're just trying to make money.
I mean they don't really care,
but when you're dealing with privatized
prisons and you're also dealing with
prison guard unions that are trying to
keep people in prison,
so they have prison guards that have
jobs.
I mean,
you're,
you're not dealing with a whole system
where the entire system is dedicated to
actually rehabilitating people.
That sort of bullshit.
They pretend it is there.
It's just a system.
Someone can start a company,
you know that,
that,
that donate.
That basically is a charity that we give
them to.
These people donate money and we give
people these vitamins,
these Omega three and vitamin D and
multivitamins in prison.
People are not gonna.
They're going to say,
listen,
if you want to give people nutrients and
vitamins,
give it to poor people.
Give it to poor people that haven't
committed crimes,
don't ever
give it to prisoners.
Don't try to fix presidents.
I see what you're saying.
I see your point of view,
but I,
I see how people are going to say,
if you're going to start somewhere,
don't start with people that have
already fucked.
We should definitely start with.
We should definitely give him the poor
people also.
I mean,
you know,
we need to make sure that,
that these people that can't afford to
eat all these greens and fish every day,
we can at least give them a fish oil
pill and you know,
a vitamin D pill and multivitamin to
help give,
give him some of those micronutrients,
particularly the children that are not
doing well and on their cognitive tests
and having behavioral problems and it's
like people don't want to ever think
about the fact that nutrition plays a
role in that.
It's not just all genetics,
it's not all environment and you know,
in terms of being abused or.
I mean that definitely plays a role for
sure that there is,
there is a component of nutrition that
we can control to some degree and it's
cheap.
It's a cheap solution.
Vitamins aren't that expensive.
I mean,
relatively speaking you can,
you can get a Omega three pill,
vitamin D,
pill,
multivitamin,
and it's not that much money a month.
Now there was something else that you
said that you wanted to talk about.
The Dave asprey had said that was
incorrect.
That was the epigenetic tests.
Uh,
they,
uh,
the Swedish study I had listened to the
podcast that you'd had some time ago and
you know,
he's got good information,
I don't want to say otherwise,
but it was just,
I wanted to correct that because he had
said that the,
the children from the well fed,
uh,
the ones that were grandchildren of the
well fed children lived,
got type two diabetes less.
That was completely wrong.
It was,
it was the opposite.
Yeah.
He's a collector of interesting ideas
and uh,
although I liked the guy,
he gets shit wrong and I don't know if
he's always that good about recognizing
when he has done that and correcting
themself.
We,
we've had a real issue with him as of
lately because of microtoxins.
I don't know if you're aware of the
whole issue of micro topics.
A little bit about it.
Um,
yeah.
I'm not concerned about mycotoxins and
coffee.
I'm more concerned about not getting my
Omega three and all the other
micronutrients and involved in.
I mean aflatoxins certainly something I
don't want,
but that's peanuts.
So mycotoxins in peanuts are a real
issue as well.
And corn,
that's a.
that's another real issue.
Here's the issue.
This guy is selling coffee and now we're
selling this coffee through on it.
That was supposed to be the cure to this
issue.
Is this the coffee microtoxins?
No,
you're actually drinking Hawaiian Kona
coffee that I started drinking.
I started drinking right after we got
our results back on the mycotoxins
tests.
So his.
His contention was that 70 plus percent,
whatever it was of all coffee,
is infected with mycotoxins and they
make you sick.
That make the coffee tastes bitter.
They make it tastes
bad and then make you feel bad.
I took too much of this at face value
and parotid,
a lot of the things that he said and
then we decided to start looking into it
ourselves.
Well,
they've known about mycotoxins and
coffee for a long time.
There's a pub med study from 1980 about
mycotoxins and coffee.
It's always been an issue,
but they've been able to resolve that
issue with wet processing,
wet processing.
The.
They know how good coffee providers know
how to eliminate this from coughing.
We tested for random coffees to random
one starbucks,
one random bag from whole foods,
one coffee that we sell,
which is the upgraded coffee that Dave
produces,
which is good coffee,
good single source coffee,
and another one called caveman coffee.
None of them tested positive for
mycotoxins and so we'll have 70 percent
of all co coffee as mycotoxins and we
had three bags other than the upgraded
coffee.
None of them are taking is upgraded,
quote unquote bulletproof process,
which you won't resolve.
You know,
he won't reveal what this process is
publicly.
And so I kind of feel like it might.
There's some bullshit there for sure.
It's not,
there's no way we're going to find four
bags of coffee and test them.
So our friend Tate,
who runs bulletproof coffee,
he tested two bags and his coffee and
this upgraded coffee and allegedly he
found below threshold levels of
mycotoxins in Dave's coffee.
So I didn't know.
I didn't conduct that test.
I wasn't a part of that test.
I don't know if it's right,
but what the fuck,
you know,
like I feel like when you're a guy who's
running on and doing these kinds of
interviews and spewing out all these
facts,
you have to be really fucking careful.
You know,
you have to be really fucking careful to
what you're saying is true.
And if what you're saying turns out to
not be accurate and I find out that
you're profiting from what you're
saying,
it becomes,
it becomes bad.
It becomes a real problem.
And we,
that's where we are with this upgraded
coffee thing.
Um,
we still sell it at,
on it because it is really good coffee.
But we've removed all of our,
all the literature on the mycotoxin
issue,
all of the literature on that.
Because when you talk to the people that
are in the know in the coffee industry,
coffee growers,
people who grade coffee and rate coffee,
they actually have a rating system that
is a,
you know,
like you'd get a 94 and 95 and you have
excellent coffee.
Well,
your coffee loses points of a test
positive for mycotoxins.
They test it,
you know,
so he's,
he's sort of created this issue and you
know,
and made this issue out to be like,
there's a reason why you have bitter
coffee.
It's a mycotoxin.
Well,
no it's not.
It's fucking burnt coffee,
man.
Things are better.
And coffee.
Yeah,
you,
if you leave it on the pot and then he
stays heated,
it gets,
it gets bitter.
I mean,
that's,
they've known that for years.
There's,
there's no studies out there that show
that coffee with mycotoxins in it.
Test bidder and you also like this shit
of him saying that all these different
coffees have tested positive for
mycotoxins.
There's no tests.
He's got no results.
Like you can't just go around saying
that without producing the data
publicly.
You have to have to.
I've never,
I mean,
I certainly,
like I said,
aflatoxins one thing where,
you know,
that certainly can cause cancer.
Um,
I've never really been that concerned
about mycotoxins in my coffee being a
carcinogen.
I'm more concerned about my own
metabolism generating reactive oxygen
species because that's generating more,
you know,
reactive oxygen species.
Then in some micro toxins in coffee.
And that's,
that's,
you know,
well,
mycotoxins,
most certainly existed.
They existed.
Human breast milk,
how about that?
I'm sure they exist.
I mean I've gotten mycotoxin loopy after
all.
They're starting to read the different
areas where mycotoxins have been found
or aspects of mycotoxins that can affect
human health.
But the coffee one,
they seem to have licked.
They know what the fuck it is,
they know what causes it and they know
how to deal with it.
It's called wet processing.
They know how to not store beans where
they can get moldy.
They know how to prevent these things
from happening.
So this guy,
they have incentive to do that.
So this guy is sort of,
you know,
he used my platform in a way that I
don't think is totally ethical and you
know,
he claims that he's telling the truth
and he claims that,
you know,
if you sign a nondisclosure agreement,
he'll show you always,
you know,
all his testing methods like.
But it's,
it seems to be bullshit.
And I feel bad because I liked the guy
and I think that,
first of all he's not.
I mean,
he's a collector of ideas.
He doesn't have a formal education in
education,
in nutrition.
This is not something that he's got a
phd and he's not,
you know,
essentially is what I'm saying.
So,
you know,
when I talked to you about it,
I'm getting it from someone who went to
really good schools and you do research
every day for a fucking living with
that's what you do.
I do.
Um,
and,
and like I said,
I'm not an expert in microtoxin,
but I've sort of not really been worried
about it and coffee,
just based on the little bit of reading
that I've done,
I haven't,
it hasn't,
seems like it can be an issue if you
have mycotoxin infested,
infected coffee.
But if,
if it does take,
it's really infected.
We're talking like,
you know,
if it's like,
if there's a trace amount of it,
you know,
I don't really think it's,
that's the,
well that's what we found.
Well that's not what we found.
What we found is the zero.
But what tate,
my friend tate and caveman coffee found
in his is below threshold levels of two
different types of mycotoxins.
Which is not gonna Affect you at all?
Well,
not only that,
they say that anything that's gonna
increase the expression of genes that
are involved in stress resistance can
have a little bit of a hormetic effect
possibly.
That's interesting.
Yeah.
Well,
the other thing was that the actual
process of roasting the beans destroys a
huge amount of the microtoxins.
A huge amount of the mold gets.
It's,
gets killed 70 to 80 percent in some
cases.
It's reminds me,
there's this whole linkedin thing
is another thing when you're saying he,
you know,
that someone destroys the roasting
process,
destroys the microtoxin.
Well,
this whole thing with lectins.
Two,
that's a big,
uh,
I don't know who,
you know,
who started this linkedin thing,
I think maybe Mercola,
Mark Macola,
but I think he,
he talks about it all.
So,
um,
and it's like,
oh,
you can't eat beans because beans have
lectins and lectins cause an immune
response in your gut.
And this is going to cause leaky gut.
And that's not the whole story.
It's,
it's a little more complicated.
For one,
lectins are activated by heat.
And so unless you're chewing raw kidney
beans or lentils,
you're probably not activating an immune
response in your gut.
And actually beans are really high in
fiber and fiber gets broken down into
short chain fatty acids,
which actually prevents the immune
response in your gut.
So it's actually doing the opposite.
Um,
you know,
so there's,
there's people,
some people have good information,
but they also have some bad information.
And Yeah,
I agree with you.
You gotta be careful.
I mean anyone that's offering you like a
magic bullet,
like this is,
this is it,
this is the cure.
This is,
there's,
it's complicated and they're straight
up.
And I should be clear when I say that my
roasting,
the roasting process supposedly
eliminates mycotoxins.
It's just destroys the mold that causes
the Mycotoxins,
which is the source upstream of it.
Yeah.
You're roasting doesn't actually destroy
mycotoxins,
but it does destroy the mold.
The 70 to 80 percent of it in some
cases.
So it's another one of those cases where
there's too much to know.
There's too much to learn.
And I have a guy on,
he says he's an expert in some of the
things that he says seemed to be
bullshit and that's the big one that
everyone has mold in their coffee except
me.
I know how my super secret way of
getting rid of him,
but I fucking bought it.
So here we have a problem that uh,
we've allowed to be created,
but I don't,
I'm not drinking anymore.
Um,
because of that,
just at a general principle will
probably eventually stop selling it.
It is good coffee.
It's good.
Single source coffee.
There's nothing wrong with the coffee.
Just for me.
I prefer the coffee from Hawaii.
I love Kona coffee.
It has a really great taste to it.
So I just started drinking that.
Upgraded coffee.
Yeah.
Well,
not only that,
a lot of people would buy it based on
this premise that has not been proven
that most coffee has mold in it with no
fucking evidence whatsoever to back that
up.
I haven't seen any evidence that most
coffee has microtoxin and I haven't seen
evidence that it has levels of micro
toxins that are harmful.
So,
you know,
there was one test that showed that in
the bitterness area,
there was one test that showed that
mice,
when they were given saccharin infused
with Mycotoxins,
tended to avoid that Saccharin with,
uh,
with microtoxins.
But,
but saccharin sweet thing,
I mean,
it's a sweet product.
I who knows why they're avoiding the
taste of the Mycotoxins,
who knows if their bodies have figured
out that it's fucking poison.
I mean,
I don't know,
but running around saying that the
reason why coffee is bitter is because
of just stating it as fact.
Tenants the same thing that's in the
Canon.
So that's what,
that's,
that's why that's the bitter part.
Coffee and,
but he causes that.
Uh,
no,
they're naturally in,
in,
in the plants and it gets burned.
That burnt taste,
you know,
I don't know.
That burnt taste hasn't been done
enough.
Research to know what the he does to
that process.
It's possible.
Yeah.
Well that's what they say mean.
The coffee experts say when I fucking
read more about coffee over the last
three weeks than I've ever wanted to
read or thought I would ever have to.
Um,
but coffee experts,
here's where it gets pretty clear all
call bullshit,
all of them call bullshit.
And what are you saying?
They all clapped bullshit across the
board,
not just coffee providers,
not just coffee growers with coffee
tasters,
coffee experts across the board think
that what he's saying is horseshit.
That's usually a good sign.
This one guy who's not even a fucking
nutrition expert and he's not,
it doesn't have a phd in nutrition.
He comes along with these incredible
claims and also has this incredible
method to alleviate this ailment.
I mean,
it's one of those classic examples,
you know,
create a problem and then offer a
solution profit,
you know?
And that's,
that's,
it seems to be what's been done here.
Whether or not it's intentional or not,
I don't even think it was intentional,
but I think that he's one of those guys
that once he goes down a path to say he
was wrong or two to try to win some
other product on something,
it's hard to then say you were wrong
situation where it's.
Yeah,
it's,
it's tricky because it's not bad coffee.
It's good coffee.
It tastes good.
It's,
you know,
from our testing,
it's mycotoxin free.
It's single source coffee.
If he just sold it as that,
it would be a really good product.
There's nothing wrong with it.
The other thing about coffee experts is
they want to know when it was,
when it was roasted,
they want to know.
They want to know like it's like there's
a time between when the coffee's roasted
and how long you should keep it while
it's still fresh.
The he doesn't offer that.
It doesn't have any of that.
So they're calling bullshit on that too
though.
If you really cared about coffee,
you would let let us know when it's
roasted.
Should have an on a roasted by date or
roasted on date.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It sounds like it's pretty fricking
complicated.
It's too complicated.
I have children and jobs and things to
do.
I don't have time to deal with this
shit,
but I've,
you know,
I am obligated now because I got thrust
into this situation.
It's nice to talk to someone like you to
clear up some of the misconceptions of
health and nutrition and to find out
what's real and what's not and what what
are issues.
When I talked to a guy like Brian
dunning was like,
you don't need vitamin C.
You don't need this.
You don't need that,
but look at him.
He's fucking totally shaped as fat and
just not taking care of his body.
He's a no nonsense guy who got fucked
because he was a kid and he was raised a
Mormon and now he's trying to counteract
that by being a skeptic I.
that's really essentially what's going
on,
but that guy can fuck with people's
heads because he's not an expert.
He's clearly not an expert in a lot of
things,
so he really shouldn't be reviewing
scientific literature in my opinion,
like he needs to get some people that
really know how to do that.
If he's going to start trying to
critically analyze science.
That's my opinion because I've read some
of his stuff where he's trying to
critically analyze it.
For example,
um,
this,
this linus pauling,
he's got something on his website
talking about how a vitamin C can't,
has no effect on cancer incidents or can
help if you already have cancer,
can help,
you know,
kill the cancer cells.
And He puts up these studies by the Mayo
Clinic that couldn't repeat these early
studies that were done by Linus Pauling
and cameron,
I forgot his name anyways,
I'm in the late seventies,
but you know,
anyone that's scientists will look at
that and go,
oh,
pauling and cameron gave their patients
who are cancer patients,
vitamin C intravenously.
And they did that for a reason because
you can only orally absorbed so much
vitamin C and we'll get into your
bloodstream.
But intravenously you can like,
you know,
raise it to like millimolar
concentrations.
And so,
uh,
the two mio clinic studies that repeated
it repeated it in quotations gave him
orally.
And so,
you know,
you can't,
you can't repeat a study and change the
method of administration from oral to
intravenous and say,
Oh yeah,
we repeated the study.
It didn't work.
So when your credit,
when you're critically analyzing data,
you need to focus on those sort of
details because they are actually really
important.
And a recent study just came out like
two weeks ago where they took patients,
female patients,
I had ovarian cancer and they gave them
vitamin C intravenously and they're
doing their standard chemo.
It's really hard nowadays to do any sort
of,
um,
unconventional cancer treatment that's
not,
you know,
because it's like you don't want to just
kill someone.
I mean,
it's,
it's hard.
So anyways,
they did it with the chemotherapy and it
actually killed it.
They killed the cancer cells better and
it also alleviated a lot of the negative
symptoms associated with the chemo.
And this was to study published in
science,
translational medicine,
which is a pretty good journal for
translational research.
In fact.
So
Brian,
Brian has several problems with some of
the things he puts out,
you know,
he's accused me of being a pseudoscience
shill and even after the podcast,
even after the podcast where he came on
and had all these really ridiculous
accusations that he,
he threw at me,
uh,
on his website.
And we talked about them one by one,
what I believed and what I actually
didn't believe,
what I said and what I didn't say,
and he ran after basically just
tapping them out mentally for three
hours just over and over and over again.
You're wrong here.
You're wrong there.
This is silly.
This is dumb.
This is poor thinking.
He went and wrote this really distorted
thing on his website.
This is really bizarre account.
I mean,
he was very kind to me,
said he was.
I was nice and funny,
but here's why.
Thanks.
I still promote dangerous pseudoscience,
but if you look at the videos that that
guy puts out himself,
he's got this video on fracking and how
safe fracking is and how not no need to
worry about fracking.
And he's got this really hilarious smug
video on the reality of fracking or
hydraulic fracturing or fracking fucks
up environments permanently.
All threads with.
It's been over a thousand instances of
poison wells in this country because of
fracking documented,
documented instances of poisoned wells.
I mean,
they fucked up huge parts of this
country pretty much forever because of
fracking.
So what is fracking day like?
How do they?
Well,
it's a very complicated process of
getting a,
getting this stuff out of the ground,
getting oil and natural gas out of the
ground,
mostly oil right?
And it involves water,
hydraulic fracturing,
and they pump water in and I'm not the
guy to be describing is this his thing
on fracking here?
Why Marvel and Fox blamed the fact that
fracking was used in the area and
investigation into this family.
First of all,
your music makes me want to kill babies.
Discovered that their wells had been
drilled directly into a shallow natural
gas deposit.
This is common.
It's not a problem with the wells.
Properly vented.
There's wasn't so gas got into their
water.
How do we know it had nothing to do with
fracking?
Water wells range in depth from a few
meters to a few hundred at the very
deepest,
but fracking takes place kilometers
deeper.
Past numerous layers of bedrock years of
study have proven what geologists have
always known.
There's just too much distance of solid
rock between the two regions for any
seat,
but just to take place.
Stopped at this camera right here.
That's such total horse shit.
He's just parroting the words of the
people that have been paid by these
companies that are making fucking
trillions of dollars to say.
I mean that's what he's doing.
These,
these piss-poor studies,
these,
these people that have been documented
on all these various documentaries like
there's.
There's,
there's the two ones on the gas land,
one and gas land too,
but then there's also people that have
done interviews and showing how they can
light their fucking water on fire now
and showing how their,
their wells are poisoned.
People who have been really made deathly
ill by drinking what they thought was
filtered water,
but it's not filtered enough because
some of the chemicals from fracking got
into the water,
proven that those are the specific
chemicals that are in their water that
got there from fracking and this is.
He's just one of those fucking guys.
There was no nonsense.
Guys,
don't worry.
The government says it's okay,
we're fine,
but even his tone that's such an
affected tone.
That's like a fake way of talking.
He's talking like this,
like reassuring you.
That's such nonsense fucking talk,
you know,
I don't know much about fracking but I
can tell you just from reading his
trying to criticize science,
he's got a very topical understanding of
it and you know,
when I was reading some of his stuff,
like I was just like,
this guy shouldn't be doing this.
Like,
you know,
it's very,
very naive understanding and so if
you're gonna try to criticize,
criticize something and turn and say
it's not true,
then you really need to know what you're
talking about or get some frequent
experts that are really new.
He's got some real problems with this
thinking and I think he knows it.
He sent me an email asking me about
psychedelics,
asking me about psychedelics in mind.
Expanding.
I think he knows he's fucked up.
I really do.
He saw also indicted by the you mean
he's going to jail?
He's,
he's,
he's involved in an Ebay scam.
Scam them from millions of dollars.
I didn't want to talk about it on the
podcast,
but after you talk shit about me and go
fuck himself,
he,
he's,
he was involved in this Ebay scam where
they were,
uh,
they were cookie stuffing,
stuffing cookies.
You,
you'd go to use an application and I
don't,
I don't know the full details of it,
but it,
he's in real trouble.
And you pleaded guilty and he's a felon.
She was asking you about psychedelics.
It's,
it's very
well.
I think he wants to try to figure out
what the fuck's wrong with his thinking.
Well,
I just,
I really think that it has to do with
growing up Mormon.
I really think that there's,
there's,
it's not a small amount that it fucks
your head up when you grow up in a
fundamentalist mindset when you were
told that there's a man in the sky that
Joseph Smith told his disciples about
and that there's golden tablets at the
last work of Jesus and this guy found
him when he was 14.
I mean all the shit that you have to
believe to be a mormon.
This guy bought into that hook,
line and sinker,
and that's how he grew up.
That's how he grew up as a child.
That's how he grew up as a teenager.
That's how we grew up as a man,
until he refuted it and,
and your thought process.
Now he just doesn't believe anything.
It's like,
okay,
well,
everything that I was told throughout my
life is wrong.
So then everything else,
if you just googled dangers of fracking,
there is a tremendous amount of
information out there about fracking,
about what's bad,
about fracking,
about the dangers.
And we had Peter Schiff on the podcast
who's,
uh,
you know,
economic genius,
very smart guy,
but also owns fracking companies.
And he was talking about it and when I
brought it up to him,
he didn't deny the dangers of it.
What he said was,
look,
those people got money and they got
millions of dollars because of that.
Like,
that's a great thing for them.
Like in his mind,
millions of dollars is okay to poison
places forever.
I mean,
it's,
I'm no fracking expert.
I don't claim to be a fracking expert,
but if one fraction of what is said
about fracking,
the negative aspects of fracking is
true.
It's a tricky thing.
It's a very tricky thing.
Yes,
we could use the natural resources.
Yes.
You know,
uh,
it would be nice to not be dependent on
foreign oil.
However,
if you really are destroying thousands
of wells,
if that's really is documented,
if really people are getting sick from
drinking water that's contaminated with
a very chemicals that they use for
fracking,
you know,
that doesn't seem like it's good.
That seems like that's something that
most people are not aware of.
And when you find out who are the people
that are,
that are funding these studies that are
saying it's safe and where's the money
coming from?
A lot of it's coming from these oil
companies.
A lot of it is coming from these oil
companies and the reason why these,
these,
these laws are in place in the first
place.
A lot of it is because people have been
greased,
a lot of is people been paid off.
They understand that there's a lot of
money to be made in this and they've
allowed the doors to be open for these
companies to come in and fuck up giant
parts of the country forever.
Not according to Brian Dawning,
don't worry.
Hydraulic fracturing takes place
kilometers into the earth.
Right.
Sleep tight.
Don't worry about Ebay.
Poor bastard.
I liked him.
He's not a bad guy too,
but you know,
he said after the podcast,
he said he would remove me from his
list.
He said,
you've convinced me.
I'm going to remove you from my last.
Then from just getting crushed by people
online,
the poor,
poor guy got destroyed on twitter
because people listened to the podcast.
We're so frustrated by him and the
ridiculous way he thinks and the
ridiculous things that he was saying.
Yeah,
just the same pod.
It must have been the same one.
I had only been online.
Sorry.
Okay.
That was so infuriating.
Yeah.
That's.
You know,
I,
I haven't seen all your podcasts,
but I can tell that you're.
You don't seem to be a promoter of
pseudoscience.
You seem to be an inquisitive person
that likes to critically think about
things and you're also very open minded.
So it's like,
well,
what if this is,
you know,
let's think about,
let's think about how this could be
working in.
What if it is true?
It's not,
you know,
there's,
there's a difference between thinking
like that and,
and pseudoscience where you're just
like,
you know,
you're just crazy and like you're
thinking,
oh,
there's the.
I don't think he can see the reference.
Yeah,
the differentiate between someone that's
actually just inquisitive and open
minded and doesn't see things as okay,
it's either this or that and you know,
maybe there's something that we don't
understand and you know what,
there is a lot that we don't understand.
Like it's even even for just back to
nutrition,
you know,
like taking,
eating a plate full of green vegetables,
what we think we're getting vitaminK and
folic acid and magnesium,
but there's a whole bunch of crap in
there.
We don't know what it's doing.
We don't know what's in there and what
it's doing and how it's affecting,
you know,
processes in our body and we do know
that there's good stuff going on in
there and things that we don't even
understand.
So yeah,
there's a lot of stuff that we just,
we can't explain yet.
We're trying to.
I'm not sure
a concern would look like a fool.
So if something comes up and I go,
where is that possible?
Is that true?
[inaudible] let's,
let's think about if that's possible.
There's a lot of people that are very
concerned about looking like fools that
won't go down those roads.
They won't say something absolutely
ridiculous,
you know,
like,
do you think the CIA really did kill
Kennedy?
Let's think about it.
You think it's possible for them to kill
Kennedy?
The,
a lot of people that go,
oh,
come on now,
look,
Lee Harvey Oswald acted alone.
Case closed.
We're done here.
You know,
they want to be that no nonsense guy.
That doesn't look like a fool.
But the problem is there's a lot of
nonsense in the world and if you really
look into things openminded,
you find that there's some gray and
everything in almost every subject.
There's some fucking weirdness.
I agree 100 percent for Brian dunning.
All I have to say to him is I'm hired
some people that like know how to,
you know,
read science and critically analyze it.
If you're going to call yourself a
science writer for God's sake,
you know?
Yeah.
Well the people like that along with
people like Dave Asprey,
who got the information on the,
uh,
the study,
the dietary study incorrect.
There is a real problem with those guys
because they're not a guy like me who's
not a fucking expert in anything.
Look,
if you asked me questions about martial
arts,
if you ask me questions about standup
comedy,
I can give you the opinion of an expert.
I am a true expert in those very small
areas.
That's it.
When you talk to me about anything else,
I'll go,
I fucking read some shit online.
I read a book.
I'm not an expert,
but when people start spouting shit out
as fact,
I'm learning on this podcast that there
is a big responsibility that I'm
learning how,
how the,
the pitfalls of having people spouting
things as fact that aren't necessarily
factual
and you know what?
I know a lot about nutrition and science
and there is a
hello,
have a law that I do not know.
Well,
I love that you're honest about it.
Know like when I asked you about amino
acids in India,
taking them without water,
you're right away.
I don't know,
but that's great.
That's how the world should be.
The guys like Dave Asprey,
you ask them,
they come up with a fucking answer
because they don't want to look stupid
and that answer might be a wise was
coffee bitter mycotoxins.
Are you fucking sure?
Where's your task that show Mycotoxins,
make coffee bitter.
You don't have anything man.
You gotTa stop doing that.
You've got to stop.
You're confusing the fuck out of me.
And then I parrot what you're saying.
I confused the fuck out of a bunch of
people and that happens a lot.
Like I said,
you know,
he,
he also talks about the lectins and the
beans and it's like and recall it as the
same thing where it's like,
you know,
these,
they have some good information,
you know,
these people have,
there are some good things that they
say,
but there's also some information that's
totally wrong and the problem is people
think because they have one good piece
of information that everything they say
is right and it's not,
you know,
and that's where you get this parenting
where it's like,
well there's a meme now.
It's like,
I don't know who started it,
but someone started it and it's not
accurate.
Right.
They didn't dig deep enough.
They don't understand enough of the
science behind it.
And so then you get everyone following
this,
this big following and it's like,
you know,
like how do you come in and say,
okay look,
this is how it's really happening.
And that's kind of what I'm trying to do
in some degree it's not easy and I'm
doing it in my spare time because I'm
also still doing research.
So I'm like,
on weekends I'm like writing articles
and making videos instead of going out
and the bay area,
you know,
but I freaking love doing it.
So.
Well listen,
I've really enjoyed this conversation.
I think you've opened up a lot of
people's eyes and you've educated a lot
of people and provide a lot of
information.
Almost too much information is.
I'm definitely seeing people writing
down all these different things in
googling all these different things that
you've said,
but I think we could have this
conversation 100 times.
I really do.
And if you ever want to come on again,
I would love to have that again and tell
people what,
you know,
your videos,
where can they find them
tube.
So if you go to my page,
found my fitness.com
and really just kind of ski down the
social media slopes,
you know,
I've got really there's three ways
people can help me.
One is by,
by subscribing to my podcast or my
itunes and my youtube channel to really
help me keep going and also at found my
fitness,
my podcast,
the name of the podcast.
That's the name of my,
that's my twitter name,
that's the name of my podcast.
I also have a patrion campaign they
could help me with.
That's kind of like a kickstarter,
but it's,
you can contribute like twenty five
cents a month and that's to help me pay
for my podcasting,
like to host my podcasting and it's
really just to help me continue doing
what I'm doing like on weekends and in
my free time.
Um,
and lastly is signing up for my
newsletter.
I know that's not that cool these days,
but I actually put a lot of good
information.
My newsletter,
I'm going to put it this link to this
new study on,
on the sauna that I was talking about
that it's coming out in a couple of
weeks.
That's awesome.
Yeah.
So I would love to come back and talk
about,
you know,
absolutely everything and this paper on
Serotonin's coming out and a couple of
weeks,
actually six days.
So look for that and I'll probably send
you a link going.
Okay,
send me anything.
I'd be happy to tweet it.
It's so important to me to have people
like yourself that are actual experts
with legitimate credentials that can
separate and clear the fog on a lot of
these issues and I'm,
I'm,
I'm fucking not tolerating this anymore.
If someone comes in and they have all
these clams,
they don't have information to back up
the clients.
I'm just going to fucking keep.
Hit me up anytime we have a question.
I will.
I will dig into it.
Like I'm going to look into some of the
stuff you talked about today that I
didn't know about.
Beautiful.
And so,
um,
so thank you very much.
It's really is.
It's so important to have someone like
yourself who's an expert that's willing
to take the time to come on a podcast
and educate us.
So I really appreciate it.
So you can follow Rhonda on twitter.
It is found my fitness on twitter and
that is also the name of the podcast
found my fitness.
Anything else you want to say to people?
Yeah,
let's just what I said the three ways
they can help me out,
man.
I would really be great.
Go help her out.
Help her out.
This was a hugely entertaining and
educational podcasts.
You're really good at this.
You should have your own podcast.
Oh,
you do.
It's found my fitness and it's on
itunes.
Go get it folks.
Uh,
thanks to our sponsor.
Thank you to Tang.
Go to Rogan Dot Ting Dot com and save
$25 off your mobile device with a lovely
network Ting,
Rogan.ting.com.
Thanks also to on it.
Go to o,
n n I t use the Codeword Rogan and save
10 percent any and all supplements.
That's it for this week.
Next week though.
Lots of cool people coming in.
Ladies and gentlemen,
we've got a lot of shit happening and
thank you for all the love,
all the love on twitter.
All the love on facebook and the all the
positive responses that we get and all
the cool people that I meet that tell me
how much this podcast enhances your life
and enhance his mind to.
And it wouldn't be nothing without you
guys.
So thank you so much.
Keep it together.
We're all in this as one big kiss mom.